bienvenue à sans filtre super jeu quand
tu es avec moi de dôme plantes
pourtant on a reçu pl cloutier
l'influent soeur numéro un au québec
selon les 18 34 ans que pour ce qui vaut
rien on a eu une super belle
conversation ses smartphones on a parlé
beaucoup son parcours bien sûr comment
il s'est rendu à être le meilleur
meilleur influenceurs au québec on a
parlé de charge électrique
pl y conduire votre piste passionnés et
connaisseurs décharge électrique
l'apport de tous on a parlé de quoi son
livre son livre est toute polémique avec
sophie durocher je peux savait se passer
alors on revient là dessus un petit peu
dans les commentaires sur cette vidéo si
n'hésitez pas à participer à la
discussion de ton lit tous les
commentaires on essaie de réagir le plus
possible avec vous aussi évidemment
proposer des invités vous voulez avoir
une moto intéresse toujours de lire
c'est propositions là et sinon
évidemment abonnez-vous à notre chaîne
pour rester à l'affût de tous les
podcasts qui vont sortir à chaque mardi
avec des invités de plein d'horizons
différents donc pour être au courant de
cas ça sort abonnez vous
sinon bon pas de castres bonne écoute ps
merci coup là d'ici là ça va ça va très
bien j'existais de vos déchets est
partie de votre installation si vous
venez un jour faire mon podcast va les
voir c'est beaucoup plus gâteau derrière
est ce qui est tout le temps là j'avais
pas remarqué le laisser comme ça
attention à payer des droits d'auteur
la prochaine fois je vous amènera une
photo de moi que vous pourrez je me
chargerai pas de rendre au drapeau un
groupe comme bois grandeur nature de toi
d'ailleurs mais c'est que ça existe j'en
ai deux chez moi et un ben oui c'est
quand mon livre est aussi la maison
d'édition trouvais ça drôle de faire
faire des présentoirs grandeur nature de
moi taxé comme le haut de mon corps avec
une jambe puis l'autre jambe c'est comme
des trucs pour un présentoir de l'x dans
le forfait commis dans les librairies
[ __ ] les abonnés se prennent en photo
avec moi ils mettent une tuque simard en
tâche de fond
j'en avais chez moi parce que je faisais
comme des dédicaces dans mon lit je t'ai
pas capable de garder ce chez moi fac
gym et efface contre le mur jamais passé
c'est vrai c'était pour la tournée promo
télé
ouais exact puis ça a été quand même nom
mais y en ait encore certaines
librairies qui ont un long le présentant
qu'une ailleurs au québec le mois je
n'ai pas vu encore en magasin mais je
les vois ça fout moi quand j'avais fait
qu'un frère pour les éditions passe
temps puis j'avais écrit des livres
jeunesse qui étaient les écoles les
écoles primaires un peu partout au
québec et a fait faire un gros grosses
figures de cartons d'un personnage qu'il
avait créé qui s'appelait maquis c'est
comme un singe et inventeur fait que les
jeter au salon du livre de québec à côté
de ma pancarte de singes puis puis les
liquides passe à côté puis il voyait un
influenceur créateurs de contenu numéro
1 une influence arrêt numéro 1 des
québécois j'arrête pas niaiser avec son
enveloppe
vous savez j'ai pas changé les lanceurs
chouchou des québécois - rien fait mon
plaisir hein
une histoire à la maison bulle là rien
de compliqué là les canapés le caviar
dont elle jouit je suis c'est le sondage
léger marketing ça fait deux sondages
l'avait pas dit qu'il faisait ça c'est
arrivé comme une cerise et ouais enfin
sondages et d'études baisse comme une
étude scientifique pour comprendre les
milenio projette pas oui voilà il faut
savoir qu'il faut dire les millé nario
scénario s'est pas encore plus jeunes ce
mais je pensais en français parce
qu'après dix villes milenio c'est un
anglicisme le millénaire faisait c'était
comme une étude pour comprendre c'est
quoi leur goût est maintenant parmi
toutes ces banques laquelle vous
préférez si vous dépensez comment vous
dépensez votre argent quelle compagnie
de cellulaire est votre favori
on est comme plein de questions puis il
ya aussi vos influenceurs pressing et on
était ils m'ont donné le titre de numéro
un parce que c'est mon nom qui sortait
le sondage le plus souvent mais dans le
top 3
il ya même pas jean 1% de décors faconde
et romero 7 et alicia toi élisant way a
récemment fêté les emmena dos un
troisième place mais tourner c'était
tellement sert il que j'en ai les trois
numéros en mai prochain pour comme
j'aurais le double de alicia où elles
ont vraiment peur et bravo
il est depuis est-ce que ça changeait
d'avis pied vous avez guerrier que j'ai
chez moi des vidéos fait par mon décor
de podcasts ghetto non ça rien changé à
part commentaire to short est flatteur
quand même mais oui parce que air en
plus la méthodologie qui ont employé
pour faire ce sondage là ça ressemble
vraiment à celles qui utilisent pour le
gala artis du et quand même mais majeur
c'est pour hâter vo tous attaqué c'est
sûr que c'est comme
on peut pas dire à ce que les andral a
tellement fait une grosse campagne pour
qu'on vote pour elle c'est vraiment ça
s'est fait à notre insu fait que c'est
vraiment moi ça m'a vraiment surpris
parce que je suis pas dans une année où
je fait grand chose si je suis vraiment
sur un hard allez disons mon livret de
l'année dernière ma tournée de spectacle
est terminé
j'ai ralenti la cadence beaucoup sur mes
chaînes youtube fait de savoir que
d'instantanés mans dans un sondage il ya
des gens qui ont eu envie de me nommer
je trouve ça vraiment surprenante je
m'attendais passe bravo merci vous savez
je sais pas pourquoi c'est cool parce
que ça fait longtemps que tu es
d'enquêté dans cette game là j'espère
que je tellement vieux revoici la maison
dévoile mon âge parce qu'il fait la
blague avec mes abonnés le dit depuis le
début que moi j'ai toujours 25 ans j'ai
fait une tournée de spectacles où on
fêtait mais 25 un soir après soir 17
s'attaque à chaque fois qu'un
journaliste révèle manouche commenté
dans mes cordes
en tout cas bref ça va faire cinq ans
que je suis et j'ai commencé à 25 ça
fait 5 un g25 non c'est pas vrai cette
année j'ai j'ai fait une vidéo
coming out j'ai bon ben j'ai dit aux
abonnés je peux vous disent quelque
chose ça fait quand même plusieurs
années que je vous manque que je vous
dis que j'ai 25 ans et pauvres et g20
[Rires]
c'est une blague humain c'est un
mensonge sur mon art j'ai depuis
toujours je pense y est trop tard le
site allemand dévoile une entrevue il
aime sortir mais on a su contrôler puis
cet été qui délivre ses salles à manger
par rapport aux sondages chemin mais
pendant qu'on parle de ce qu'est ce que
dans le fond les trois top 3 sont son
deuil où tout est sur la liste des
débats lycée est un peu plus d'instagram
satellite mairie dans l'esprit des
québécois n'est pas grosse mais c'est
vraiment je pense à l'avoine
relativement mais après je verrai après
la voie à la craie c'est ce que fait
qu'ils apprécient sa transféré à g j'ai
l'impression
toute chose qui est curieux de savoir ce
parce que youtube on a tendance qui
avait agité victor type le mans nice est
agité vie où c'est de la merde tu sais
quoi des campagnes publicitaires mais
qu'à sa sortie c'est quand qu'ils
pourraient du value topless que youtube
ça va mourir et ce que ben et moi j'ai
comme l'impression que youtube soit son
niveau juste pour moi non plus je pense
pas que youtube est
je pense vraiment pas qu'il faut tout va
disparaître
peut-être que les youtube vont peut-être
- mais parce que ça fait quand même
offert une parenthèse souffert du
montage quoi mais j'aimais vraiment un
truc qui enregistre pas le jeu jamais
mieux y'a rien qui me fait plus chier
que faire un tournage
la vraie statue te rends compte que sans
réagir et moi ça mais en vrai c'est
notre phobie si jamais on se lève 4 papa
de casse pour aller voir ça tourne parti
ne s'est pas créé le malaise
c'est déjà arrivé dans d'autres épisodes
que vous coupiez pour aller voir mais on
coupe et après c'est tout frais vous
êtes comme scarlett c'est le podcast
rapport au montage mais regardez les
encore et encore ce n'est pas le cas
vous êtes juste lisant mes jean michel
est venu s'asseoir se disant oui pas mal
podcast l'a mené à termi gueule micro
pour lui fallait les deux ils
s'arrachent les micros c'est ce
téléphone est l'épisode mais on parlait
de youtube l'impression qu'elle est
youtube on mai par m moi j'ai pas
inquiet pour les youtube art mais ça
fait quand même mais presque cinq ans
que sur youtube puis ce qui est le plus
tôt je trouve de youtube ce qui est une
plateforme qui change sans arrêt et on
nous dit pas dans quelle direction ça va
on est en train de remettre en question
nos choix titre que nos miniature faut
te faire des vidéos langue des vidéos
courtes pourquoi le che est démonétisé
on syrien de youtube mais ce que je sais
c'est que maintenant la page d'accueil
est hyper important pour youtube et mois
de plus en plus quand je me connecte sur
la page d'accueil bcd location de films
c'est des extraits d'émissions vivo
qu'on met de l'avant qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d espace pour les youtuber et
la question à mes le cas c est ce que
youtube a besoin de youtube heures ok
moi je pense que non
bah oui parce qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment d'intérêt pour
les studios de et faisaient pas la
distribution de films
la zone qui est la base de youtube a
vraiment pris un virage à la netflix
avec des créations youtube originals
elles veulent qu'on pousse de plus en
plus youtube raid youtube musique et ont
de plus en plus de trucs qui sont comme
le système qui s'installe dans youtube 1
qu'est-ce qui reste pour l'aspect
communauté et je ne sais pas je serais
curieux moi je m'inquiète pour les
youtube a parce que on a mille et une
option au québec on et chansons d'un
star system il ya des institutions qui
existent ya jamais eu besoin d'avoir du
public pour construire des productions
au québec on finance un million
d'affaires etc et du public ou n'ont
fait que ce point que pour nous qui on
va se trouver d'autres solutions je me
demande juste que c'est pendant combien
de temps pendant combien de temps encore
on les youtube avons appris youtube leur
maison je sais pas ce qui nous fait là
tu formes qui va apparaître qui va
remplacer ce pourri mais je vois déjà
des plans du pouvoir qui sont recrutés
comme monteur dans départ des stations
de télé j'avais déjà beaucoup de
difficultés à retenir les pigistes et
que j'ai pu engager comme monteur parce
qu'ils seront recrutés pour des projets
financés moitié compétitionner à 50
dollars delà des montages content pour
eux que ces revenus là existe mais c'est
la réalité aussi sur youtube pas combien
temps avant que les yachts ou barcelone
dont il ya des plates formes
fantastiques comme nouveau comme tou.tv
la fabrique culturelle à radio-canada le
cube radio qui engage kaboom kaboom film
pour faire un podcast
il ya tellement de l'avenue trouve que
tu vas perdre petit à forte autonomie
parce que l'autre parce que tu fais tout
moi-même été le chef c'est au petit ton
propre boss tisserait to play retourner
travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre
en ce moment je suis vraiment pas comme
maintenant à moyen terme ou pas mais
entre j'espère à long terme et east
parce que tous nous disent rien qui
change tout le temps mais j'ai pas prévu
quitter youtube c'est pas mon plein mais
j'avoue qu'en ce moment je cherche des
projets qui vont me permettre de me
dépasser
parce qu'il ya une équipe qui aussi à
coeur que moins que ça fonctionne c'est
une émission de radio c'est dessus de la
télé c'est tu sais pas c'est quoi ce
moment il n'y a rien en branle
mais c'est certain que le contexte
youtube où je suis chez moi avec une
caméra sur un trépied ou je fais tout
tout seul en cinq ans j'ai un petit peu
l'impression d'avoir touché des limites
nouveau défi à chaque fois le faire ben
oui oui encore un défi parce qu'elle est
tout un défi d'aller chercher des clics
mais c'est sûr qu'à la fin de vidéo je
fais offrir des cochonneries dans ma
frite us et je connais la formule cinq
ingrédients 6 liner au niveau 2 gameiro
merci bonsoir de ses potes et c'est
quand même université que je réplique
c'est fantastique c'est génial sa mort
sa mort ouvre un milliard de portes mais
comme créateur des fois j'avais envie de
plus je compte vraiment envie de c'est
ça d'avoir une équipe qui me titille un
peu plus que moi qui tire un projet
c'est un peu seuls au monde
mais j'adore les blogs en corse pour ça
que en ce moment je publie beaucoup de
blogs un point de moins de vidéos sur ma
chaîne principale et c'est normal le
site si com et vous me dites ta gueule
un pea soup annoncé par trop longtemps
fait des conférences dans des écoles
seul pendant des heures mais
- j'ai perdu le fil de ma passe au
travers de ça mais bref ce soir j'ai
envie de projets qui m'excite qui met me
permettent de me dépasser il y aurait en
branle encore comme tu dis mais ce que
tu as décidé de la faire moi j'adore
recevoir la radio c'est un peu pour ça
que j'avais partie de broadcast y avait
de la télé j'aimerais ça mais pas sous
n'importe quelle forme
des fois je pense que les youtube ronces
imaginons les mâles à télé c'est magique
le public suit maintenant on y est et on
a des forces et des faiblesses nous
sommes tous les autres artistes pic à
camps se fait la preuve qu'à faire si tu
sais aussi qu est-ce qui va être au
montage qui se trouve donc ici c'est de
choisir ma vie un peu plus de les gens
pensent qu'on sort un livre
youpi c'est magique le monde l'achète
maison on prépare le terrain où on
n'arrive pas comme une surprise non plus
du tout à une stratégie même si des fois
ça un peu informé dans nos tribunaux
comme un plan qu'on construit même
entrecôte y ait un vrai projet de terry
je pense qu'il faudrait que ce soit
vraiment un projet où j'ai l'impression
de tenir un peu difficile parce que des
fois je trouve qu'on nous catapulte dans
des rôles que j'ai vus comme des filles
phare codef futur
on n'est pas des humoristes on n'est pas
de travailler avec des équipes de
apprend une façon de travailler ça prend
le bon le bon projet est-ce que tu seras
un projet est une chose mais tout ça je
n'ai pas fait encore non mais j'en ai
dans mon cahier géorgie oui je pourrais
producteur et animateur a maintenant un
projet qui est dessus qui tout a
commencé cinq coups dans ton je sais pas
je réfléchis
m
jeu mais c'est certain que ab trop
charmant projet qui a failli fonctionner
avec des fo qui est en ontario le ton
monte aulas comme le télé québec mais de
l'ontt et l'ontario puis on a un gros
projet ça s'appelait cesse au plc une
série de 12 épisodes ont été financés
par le fonds canadien on avait vingt
sept cent mille dollars de budget pour
faire une affaire là dessus du bois
j'étais coproducteur je m'étais associé
avec trio orange
et puis pour un million de raisons
surtout des politiques c'est un projet
avorté dans la pré production politique
c'est qu'un site comme télé québec en
fait appartient société des mots et
captant que tout l'appui de la direction
des politiciens sur des projets mais est
ce quand ils le peuvent dans une tente
on topic
faire autre chose lui côté je suis pas
de la dernière mais ça c'était il ya
trois ans on avait ce projet tu vois
j'ai j'avais demandé d'être co
producteur dessus justement pour être
certain que ce soit cohérent avec le
reste de ma chaîne qu'on puisse vraiment
harmoniser et les épisodes avec les
contenus de la chaîne youtube pour
vraiment que tu sois blême de façon
naturelle mais je n'arrive pas en finale
la diffusion avec roman du pire le foot
en parlant d'une love story puis le
succès comme pas vraiment bien planifié
ça je trouve que quand j'étais impliqué
a à z
on attendait un peu mieux les les
objectifs de tout le monde production
tout a commencé comme animateur mettons
te fait une émission à radio canada ah
oui attention oui cap sur l'été elle a
fait d'autres je pense à vue ou en
afrique pas trop j'avais fait
aubin et compagnie même si peu après
mais je sais plus comme un chroniqueur
dans le truc et je faisais chronique
dans des émissions de services
tout ça c'était avant la chaîne youtube
oui exact quand c'est ça ralentit te
fait faux cov moi je fais ma propre
affaire puis je me prends ma chance mais
ça allait pas bien mais ce sommet je les
compte et mille fois oui faire face au
wild à mes abonnés vous avez entendre
cette histoire d'un milliard de fois
pour les autres beaucoup de monde moi je
sois mon rêve c'est de faire la
télévision oui j'avais quand même été
vraiment proche d'atteindre mon rêve
avec cap sur les techniques aux belles
et compagnie et puis tout ça c'est comme
terminée puis mon contrat de verre est
renouvela cap sur l'été mais ça c'est la
télé en des fois john en main ça marche
plus pas que je commence ma chronique et
ali puis j'étais une un été où j'avais
rien à faire chez nous et j'ai ma mère
m'a passé de l'argent pour sauver mon
hypothèque sèche est vraiment le jeu
prend corps au fond du baril quand même
assez forte était au fond du baril mais
à terme on était déprimé tout le jeu me
rappelle je vous écris je vais prendre
un des six qui va se passer quoi dans ma
vie je ne faisais rien ils avaient tous
une audition gtep en 2010 sauf c'était
vraiment c'est un soir jean son ami qui
m'a vraiment dit que je devrais c'est
idiot tout mais moi je connaissais pour
se jeter comme tous mes collègues la
télévision qui n'était pas que vraiment
curieux à ce moment-là de youtube parce
qu'on est tenté lit pour faire de la
télé comme ça dans un maison showbiz par
une traditionnelle est médiocre mais
puis je comprends pourquoi parce que tu
es entouré de gens de télé puis tu étais
au quotidien dans des productions pita
du public fac c'est facile d'arrêter de
regarder ce qui se fait aux taux j'étais
content aussi
puis j'ai essayé aux tout petits ça a
été comme le bon timing ou de cette
marche est vite ben étonnamment oui mais
je laisse encore le même mot le timing
était bon
ouais parce qu'elle est ma chaîne
souvent un an et quelques mois j'avais
déjà cent mille abonnés ah ouais ça ça
arrive pour le non sens
comment et comment tu as quoi ta tribu
sûr mais tant que tu parles du timing
c'est qu'est ce que tu faisais au québec
absolument je pense que je serai prêt
aussi à y aller dans ma vie personnelle
ou un message on la connaît mais qui tu
écris va chercher je veux savoir qui tu
écris j'espère que c'est ça une cloche
c'est vrai nous un club unique dans la
peine et dans l'exposé des déportés avec
mes amis notation étaient toutes là
gagne c'est le batteur on mène on me
tender plomb choix fait pendant que 30
minutes pour mettez le csa table on a on
allumait les notifications plaire aux
gens de papa c'est quoi le bruit de la
route ou joyce et ceux ci se mettent à
faire de gueule après ce trio garder
certains et sion ont soif est
conscientisé parce que moi j'ai déjà vu
déjà fait le test j'avais j'avais dit
attendre que jeune fille pour mort comme
qu'est ce qui arriverait soit à droite
ben oui mais parce que les gauchers
remarquer il regarde pas les fiches
ils veulent juste le plus de matches
paraissent au choix germain président de
la parenthèse single on parler de quoi
avant on parlait de même pas les bonnes
doses et une centaine de tout sauf de
neige et polir la cloche pas que ça
arrivera
j'ai lu notification sur les messages
mais pas sur les matches parce qu'il
touche pas une telle masse qu'on arrête
tout ça
des bonnes expériences de détenus et
honnêtement je suis là tu pour passer le
temps ça mène à rien après quatre
messages ou devrait on arrête d'écrire
plus tu aussitôt que ça vire plate fait
l'espace j'ai douze autres matches comme
il ya quand même un côté netflix là
dedans c'est catalogue des possibilités
oct m un thème tout de suite le pied à
100%
c'est le fun jusqu'au moment qui
interagit vraiment que la personne qui
après deux phrases simples de santa
croce comme l a dit le pilote bien comme
anxieux moi je réponds tu sais quoi qui
est là pour faire jeter l'épongé du
temple qui il parle au public beaucoup
dans un pays il ya demande au public
ou est-ce que vous êtes rencontrés parce
que c'est un nom et un couple puis on
dit aux chocolats favoris et non à
juliette et chocolat qui l'a jeté comme
un sundae place océan drêche est plus qu
est-ce qui est une des cloches
ça fait quatre ans jeté un coup parce
que je sais pas trois quatre ans j'ai
peut-être je sais plus humain mais mes
dernières bêtes qui était sur le bureau
de production angy pister les bêtes les
plus mais tout a jamais dit tu es fan
ports soient maîtres dp world congress
pour jamais je pars jamais ta photo un
choix at elle rappelé c'est pas lui
des scandales ménager ses pommettes et
je dis chapeau mais c'est parce que je
cherche pas c'est que moi je peux passer
des heures à fès et cela fait assez
clément may cry qu'est ce que tu
cherches de jeu quel genre de gauche
quand même acheté un gars plate fait que
je suis plein de trucs après deux heures
et demie est trop tard m'écrire cherche
je fais rien week end j'aime pas soif à
accepter compliqué profumo pas une
sortie sans parachute vos sorties tout
seul je suis plus moi je vais aller au
salon expo habitat sion le week end je
veux magazine et femmes ont cosco jeu
suit lac
je veux vraiment pas une bonne date faqs
ça je prenne pas au bon oui
c'est de retrouver quelqu'un t'aime à
temps
didot trouver quelqu'un pour bâtir
quelque chose notons qu'un thé et je
trouve qu'à mon âge le 25 endroits où
c'est compliqué parce que lego qui sont
ceux qui ont latitude pour être en
couple les allemands sur dix qui sont le
tempérament pour pendant cette guerre
banque ces gaulois sont déjà en couple
s'ils sont comme trop soit chevaux d'été
des très jeunes vélo c'est fini mais les
noms mais à mon âge c'est très strict
des fois je prends des photos avec des
abonnés chez commun et comme ses débuts
vingtaine c'est un beau gars il son père
depuis 40 ans je suis un opéra aux gens
ce moment j'ai à mi chemin je sais pas
lequel des douches préfère je
m'intéresserai 2 pour différents très
embêtant fait que je devais projet
notifié que j'ai déchaussé bois pour
m'occuper me donnait l'impression que je
poigne est ce que c'est un vin qui
satisfait les youtube en numéro 1 du
québec sous ses pas regardants j'adore
les livres mais je les connais pas
j'avoue que ce poids et c'est peut-être
pas de lebon au no stress je sais
peut-être pas le bon verre qui s'apprend
c'est parce que j'avais dit dans des
salons du vin une fois puis le monde
fait des genres le truc appliquera
chaque homme et vous êtes tous des
enfants rois
à moi mis hors de moi un chef de l'acq
bains rue m mais on peut virer sous un
peu quand même tas de cendres au salon
de la bière salomon et on m'avait donné
un livret 30 coupons et on après douze
jeux qu'on mène pas une sale année mais
c'est parce que c'est comme un ver
dégustation le que tu avais avec une
ligne mais sont tout comme vous je te
passe la ligue tu coules c'est pour un
bien meilleur que les autres parce que
je dépasse la ligne c'est ça qui sont
tout genre dépôt des propriétaires
brasserie fait qu'ils veulent y aller
pour avoir l'air choqué j'ai pris pas
mal de coups bas mais franck que pense à
chicago je vous le conseille
salon salon de la bière à chico castillo
en plus c'est dans les terrains de
football ou you jean loup metton que le
super bowl à chicago bulls avec lui sur
le terrain sur le gazon avec des print
killers que juste d'être sur le terrain
c'était comme une expérience en sorte
d'être cool que ceux à chicago est
invité par chicago
sur la portion pub je suis coincé comme
l équivalent de montréal moment de
montréal faisait tout fait qui organise
souvent des des groupes dans le fond
pour faire découvrir ce que j'ai compris
que chicago sont vraiment compétition
avec new york dans le corps en tant que
ville touristique par clélia c'est 2-0
québécois n'y a pas juste new york
j'avais invité avec mon ami m a bossé
c'est cool cela fonctionne risques
étaient des abonnés qui sont à risque a
payé le fait que mme oda twitter une
photo d'elle pas fait parce qu'il ya un
genre d'observatoire là qu'un plancher
de verre ok moi j'ai lorsque j'ai eu ce
geste averti non j'ai pas confiance dans
les ouvriers et ça je blâme le pont
champlain
il était posé et dur il ya des siècles
était présent avec ça coûte des millions
pour faire baisser sa taxe ceux qui ont
construit le pont champlain ont sûrement
les mêmes études que ce qui en fait le
plancher de vente et les manèges à la
ronde et je vous fais pas confiance dans
les conflits le travail des gens peck
j'ai le plancher de verre non juste les
ruines romaines de 2001 qui sonne faux
de les ramener à la vie le fameux pont
le tournage êtes vous du genre à aller
le plancher de verre
moi je suis allée sautant bungie pop
tort que dimanche ouais t'as fait ça où
on est allé à ottawa
j'ai subi mois on aide à l'élaboration
par dessus lola dans l'espace de
carrière loin est le great canadian
bonne j puis c'était la première fois
que je faisais ce tout capoter g j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment unique triste est un
feeling comme il y en a pas eu avant sa
vente panique avant de sauter j'avais
aucun problème
c'est vraiment quand je suis quand j'ai
sauté plus une seconde après j'ai connu
un genre de trois secondes
parce que je pensais que mourir c'est si
bon second bloc g dans le seau poèmes et
panache et d'un zerg
parce que sept mois je me suis toujours
demandé est ce que la courbe de la
centrale en tire un peu mais sèchement
ses avant que la corde assemble de
ralentir si le respect mais oui parce
que je tire jusqu'à exact quand la corde
tir passait lot 10 et y décrocher un
rôle
j'ai même pas eu de réflexion tout ce
que je me disais on dirait que j'ai même
pas pensé kevin korjus pourquoi j'ai
sauté jamais la vie publique une comme
ton cerveau parce que tu crible dans
l'exode pendant trois secondes mais que
ça ferait qu on se mettrait pas une
crise cardiaque comme caisse parce que
c'est celle qu'a eue le 11 septembre
logique les jambes et c'est peut-être
une rencontre aux enfants pourraient
comme une écurie mais taxi arrêté avant
droit avant de frapper deux soeurs et
l'impression qu'ils étaient plus haut
premièrement avec tom plus de temps pour
ta crise cardiaque total mais je sais
pas trop comment ça pourrait fonctionner
je sais pas physiologiquement je sais
pas comment ton coeur arrête de battre
désordre je le ferais tu toi de bungie
ouais moi j'aimerais ça fout le
sachs a rien à voir mais aussi indiqué
en italie à calypso le truc avec la
porte
il ya donc ces managers est incroyable
je n'ai jamais j'ai juste lu moi puisque
la marque lada lüthi ferme la porte pour
l'été comme debout le plancher fait
juste souveraine tous deux des pipes qui
tombe tout en bas en chute libre le plat
mann heat mea a glissé et oui c'est ça
celle où mes trois même pas compte que
de faibles ou parce que juste comme je
l'aurais vu que la bt la force
centrifuge ne sens pas que que tu es en
train de faire le double mais le moment
que tout au monde
c'est mon pea je t'envoie y en a deux en
même temps on arrive au bout on se lève
pour ça regarde on n'est pas capable de
parler on était juste comme ça
avez vous pleuré
non mais on était on n'était pas cadrée
ont été jugées de toutes sortes comme si
j'aime vivre l'expérience la plus folle
la vie peut tu regardes au top le yasur
genre comme l'ado en croit notre garde
ces cas là c'est la chose la plus forte
quand ils connaissaient c'est un truc
gens qui m'avaient vraiment leur com
j'avais il y aura pas fallu vérifier
l'état de mes sous-vêtements après c'est
à las vegas j'ai fait vous savez la
stratosphère comme une espèce de tour
qui au bout de la strip pour te rendre
le faut que tu prennes la strip jusqu'au
bout tu dépasses l'hôtel tout les hôtels
qui tombe en ruine qui sont comme sur le
board et fermé que le néon qui parle des
départs et arrivées à la stratosphère
qui est comme une la tour du cn version
las vegas et là tu arrives leurs fautes
france au travers du circus circus ni
d'un autre espèce de casino en train de
fermer et creepy les tapis pu la
cigarette c'est vraiment le cellier
locaux qui vont dans cet hôtel de ses
paiements au bas de gamme n'ont qu'un
mec je me ferais jamais corps et
d'éviter par chose que je suis chicago
las vegas d'après moi j'arrive dans la
stratosphère qui est l'hôtel en ruines
on prend il ya comme les manèges et un
parc d'attraction au sommet de la tour
du cn dakhla on achète des billets pour
faire un tour de manège aux montants
aulas ensemble et saône mais j'ose tu
arrives en eau les planchers sont
croches tellement que c'est violent
cet hôtel est au sommet de cette chose
c'est je pense à sa paire jean le scream
qui fait leur [ __ ] que à la ronde qui
ont déjà acquis au sommet de la tour du
cn ont leurs beats comme est attaché
avec un harnais satrapi jamais a dit
centaine de mal dans le jeu tu avec mon
amie annie là on est attaché il ya
personne ce soir là parce qu'on est en
janvier vegas le sait au moins à partir
du mois de mai ça commençait achalandé
en janvier à personne là il faut qu'on
attende des passagers parce qu'il faut
équilibrer le manadier pas c'est fort
pour supporter notre poisson vivante you
pas d'employés pas son short staff il ya
deux manèges à fermer sur jean 4 1
finalement d'autres braves arrive avec
nous et nous installions de la musique
et des effets sonores pour jean le
départ du scream quoi 2 1 ça décolle je
vous dis là le tour le haut de la tour
du cn quand et au bout de leur vol des
genres 1,25 cern au sort des bleus je
pensais que je devenais avec mon amie
pleure et a dit je vous parlais je peux
parler parce que c'était mon idée selon
l'ars a acheté deux billets pour faire
le tour parce qu'on se donne des coups
ses fans on va voir la star il ya vingt
spéciales et on ne gaspiller notre
argent a aucune chance que je refasse
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie est
complètement con là je peux pas croire
que quelqu'un que c'est on va construire
seul c'est juste un bout de rails de
montagne russe oak est encore au sommet
de la tour d'autres sautaient même place
à mais antoine j - la stratosphère
tu es dans un wagon sur rail qui mène à
rien ta gueule ça avec vous comme si tu
allais te plonger dans le vide
maintenant ça freine jeu ça va pas faire
une part de ce fait vous j'ai eu toute
une frousse la rai a fait sauf ou comme
comme ça car c'est ce que je peux pas
croire
est-ce que tu as quel est le nom les
requins bleus au sata l'heure c'est
vraiment super je peux pas croire que
mais tu parlais de bungie j'ai vu
qu'avec passé en double il y aurait des
gens qui l'ont fait l'année
oui ces gens qui l'ont pas fait mais je
comprends je leur ai fermé je me suis
même pas rendu avec jonathan pour toi
mais je connais plusieurs personnes sur
la prévention qui ont pu aller
le vide j'ai vu passer dans mon fille de
facebook le à le clip mon ami charles
ouais mais lui a sauté car les 500
points you sorti mais sa tête est pour
elle ce comme s'ils sortaient les
piégeant j'ai quand même et votre
souvenir et s'est fait sous le jeu me
dis devant vous sans fin mais
heureusement je pense c'est impossible
que ça arrive c'est la corde participant
peut cependant une bonne seconde chez
comme ils tombent ils aient recours je
sais si j'ai eu très peu nourri mon père
lodis m'en fous du micro je veux pas
faire le poids exact il met donc en mode
le décès de pas sauté je peux comprendre
je comprends que tu arrives en wolof
s'attendent pas le ttpo choisi cette
activité le tuf et l'esprit ça se
pourrait qu'un voleur contente des ja
lynn pascoe maison juste content les
gens malades membres moi si je serai
occupation de match il faudrait qu'il
fasse la maison des geeks proposé que
100 portraits des affaires là dedans on
n'attendrait pas le froid me le premier
french on dirait mon du sahb intellon
havas qui traînent chu nord
tout le monde m'a pris des sciences ont
fait occupation double guy première
premier dimanche après le premier pays
hôte qui partait après le premier soir
où ses voyages pour le premier soit au
mieux du parti rapidement
oui c'est un bon premier soir tout le
monde aurait frencher avec tout le monde
deuxième par théo le la marque panier
mais non je pense pas aux préoccupations
orge il se serait pas la maison de
l'amour dans ce genre de maison
denjean de l'amour là dedans vous donne
une halle de béré possible justement
parce que le temps libre est trop je
m'emmerdais je pense qu'on apprenne
duchesneau a rien fait
mais c'est exact mais elle parlait de je
parle de toi vous jesse je pense d
amener des lesbiennes et des gays dans
la dans une émission comme ceux qui
mettent les lesbiennes dans maison des
gays hétéros et de mercier la maison des
filles hétéros clôture après deux
émissions à suivre en même temps parce
que ça serait des compétitions
parallèles
[Rires]
avec des étés rôti entrepris qui se
serait une nouvelle formule une ovation
mais moi j'adore qu'à chaque fois qu'il
rentre une personne bisexuelle ou pan
sexuelle c'est toujours une fille ou
aller au travail
j'adorerais voir un go bisexuels arrivée
voire beaucoup plus intéressant piti si
toujours jaurès que kiss in avait
terminé avec une fille cette année
sexuelle à manille faire des miracles en
plus nous dit que le dit qu'il
connaissait quelqu'un avant était déjà
en couple avant dans la roue des cadeaux
remis à l'état a passé son temps à
dormir d'après et visiblement brûle et
cd 105 et encore oui à l'aide soit en
sortant du bhv aujourd'hui j'avais
rencontré quelqu'un mon aventure faire
que je vais continuer avec cette
personne il ya de plus qu'on pense
qu'ils allaient que ceux qui font
semblant parce que entre d'audition puis
une maman qui parle du tarn qui peut
arriver parfois au prix de combien de
temps quand tu sais que tu fais même
temps qu'un kit appel qui disent qu'elle
te moques le 6 septembre parce que c'est
bon j'ai pas qu'est ce qui se passe à
partir de là fait qu'il faut qu'un petit
camp ciel tout faire apprécier le kenzi
savoir que je perçois comme deux mois et
demi oh ouais
en fait deux mois et demi du moment où
est-ce qu en fait on se priverait de
deux mois et demi quand six sur la
deuxième option
2 deuxième audition tu parles comme un
espèce de deux mois et demi qui la donne
puis là c'est qu'en deux mois et demi tu
peux rencontrer des témoins demi tu vois
si je m'inscrive et c'est sûr je serai
encore mais moi je pourrais pas
m'inscrire à cette juste mettons ces
choix rien j'ai la ville au complet
puisque pompe au match n 6 et je suis
limité à 6 les chances sont encore moins
fort mais en même temps si c'est des
choix et c'est du monde qui font une
présélection des fake ou moins de succès
du champion qui sont intéressants de man
et les contraintes sa force est relatif
et j'avoue c'est en tout cas la famille
argent 300 milhas des prix de transport
sont moins longtemps papillon retourne
dans son camp
oui parce que c'est le papillon je
pourrais pas faire audi mais j'adore
reste qu'à une édition de guy h
ça serait bon c'est bon comment tu
délimiterait qu'est ce qu'est la maison
des gars la maison des lobbys foulée
qu'il faudrait que chacun a son style of
pi chacun sutil puis le temps d'antenne
et celle à qui perd comme l'espèce des
chicanes qui a aussi un grand côté d'en
haut des mêmes mois c'est la première
année que j'écoute angely je t'ai pas vu
et j'ai toujours ce que je vais
collaborateurs à od plus de cours
d'ailleurs ph a fait le show dans le
début mais je craque et et comme le mec
qui mettait comme le jan de cette année
cya c'est plus le carême des stars niche
trois se sont tellement silencieux qui
mais mettons tout était le olivier de
sonner à wemmel - chante des chansons à
décines
avec les petits soupirail fils atone
ouais c'est vrai j'ai mis ça dans
l'épisode wii dit que collins ont
confirmé aujourd'hui qu'ils feraient
jamais qui gagnerait jamais eau des
puits qui gangrènent jamais la voix
olivier aurait été un excellent candidat
pour star académie qui est très bon pour
la télé réalité il est très beau mais
essayez moindrement chanté par star
academy ne ils vont tout le temps mettre
les chansons ils vont me donner des hits
fait qu'en partant tu peux pas te
tromper les mettre toutes les chansons
dans la tonalité pour que tu sois à ton
meilleur temps que y aurait été de 1,6
star academy était de retour il y aura
peut-être plus de chance le garder mais
moi j'étais jared à l'émission à rodez
plage était d'après moi pezi olivier ils
ont plus de chance de gagner un gémeaux
qu'une maison l'académicien - je crois
pas alors roman ni font semblant c'est
gros comme des filets jaunes mais elle
vit ses amis je connais c'est vrai j'ai
conscience que je dois aux des mantas
pas mon genre de trash et les candidats
facchetti non mais non mais je lis vita
chronique qui sont juste drôle mais au
lit il fait ça dans la vie pour vrai le
chanteur il fait iech enseigne et puis
aussi ou 6 août en kombustor les yeux un
album musical à rodez parce qu'ils
étaient tannés de se forcer pour creuser
un méchant problème et diarra n'ont pas
fait pas vrai il voulait se forcer dans
ma vie moi je parle tellement ça devient
la saison lundi fils comme vous et moi
je trop rires j'aimerais ça quand même
bon merde voir c'est quoi la vraie vie
me forcer pour gagner mon argent c'est
prétentieux en crise
c'est vrai ah non mais c'est un article
les gens qui prennent beaucoup
généralement des critères un peu plus
bas que les miens ça se peut pas j'ai
des amis qui ont eu toutes des dettes
cette semaine jusqu'au moins ne les
aurait pas des témoins c'est ce beau
monde parce que dans le cas de lies
trouve qu'ils sont peut-être un peu plus
beau que lui mais ça dépend de l'heure à
laquelle cruz aussi parce que si cet
hiver mais ce sera pour toi n'ont pas
appliqué août à deux heures de route
mais ça lui fait son show le tpiy jouer
au clown ce créneau comme chance a dit
oui c'est à québec
belle manière de partout ça va bien une
à maria ne parte ou qu'il en ait changé
c'est souvent pour
[Musique]
ça existe encore vous avez le droit de
voter pour la caq encore des gens québec
août a coupé tous les ponts
amigo express
je relance d'amis que j'adore ça faire
ça m'ennuie c'est l'fun ouvrés
je raconte juste mon intéressant makengo
express mais moi je suis content parce
que je commence fin du monde avec yvon
m'écoute et qui peuvent pas pis c'est
justice et c'est juste mon intéressant
c'est dit est ce que moi j'appelle ces
dix comédiens c'est des réalisateurs de
courts métrages ses charmes charge à 15
dollars mais
au début je changeais 15 mai le j'ai
appris que la norme c'était plus monté
par markit roberson pac le pead large le
faire quatre fois son gaz mettant sans
faille à s'extraire 40 pièces des
profils ces petits groupes pro forma une
voiture chargée d'engager un volt moi ça
continue à l'est je pourrais jouer à new
york avec il tombe jamais en panne
c'est comme quand et comment ça marche
quand eux puis l'électricité ça tombe
sur goss oui bon alors maintenant la
chronique voiture balai ça c'est le
segment mais la leur pourquoi c'est moi
qui fais la coupe et la chronique shore
profil bas coûts très bon pour changer
de jeu changeait des u6 les
essuie-glaces et on pense qu'on est
capable de faire cela mais le puits et
surtout quand tu ne changes pas ce qu'il
est arrivé quelque chose d'utile en
aucun cas ci n'a rien fait le petit
papier qu'un qui parle aux 20
smartphones tronic shore bon je veux
révolte roulent les premiers ça dépend
de la météo en fait plus qui fait froid
- qui fait km sur la recherche parce que
ton chauffage draine la batterie mais
dont reste une belle journée d'été puis
on baisse les finales club préfère dans
une vraiment le optimale
soixante dix kilomètres moi j'ai parié
sur 2014 le nouveau faire un peu plus
que tu peux faire des premiers 70 km sur
l'électricité et a pressé de reprendre
des sens un peu ce texte l'hiver ça dans
mon tour de québec en maintenant dans
une journée
si tu fais de la ville ce qu'avec messi
3 qui parle ouais c'est ceux là
franchement avec avec les hybrides c'est
que ton premier chantier sur
l'électricité puis après ce ne sont pas
des projets d'artistes je recharge et
c'est au printemps que ça autant que ça
prend en charge et ta retraite peut
s'apprendre et demie sur une borne
pour 1,70 clamant que ça vaut pas la
peine mais tu vois moi c'est ma seule
auto si je prends couple soumettons
quelqu'un qui serait inquiétant qui
serait en couple avec quelqu'un auto
mais le livre ou n'importe quoi de 100 %
électrique ça pour faire la job mais
vraiment pour quelqu'un de puceul
s'était jamais de l'essence de dans
leurs odeurs moi ça me coûte 40 dollars
le sens puis dans mon garage je me
branche sur une prise normale j'ai paf
installé deux bornes compliqué ou quoi
que ce soit elle cette semaine le sens
des dents au 2me moi je fais à peu près
2000 kilomètres sur un plein c'est fou
le monde à peu près 1 litres aux 100
kilomètres par la chronique c'est
vraiment intéressant par les gens
pensent que c'est charles puis c'est pas
vrai l'argent mais j'ai sauvé des
milliers de dollars défense le jeune
homme est trop bon moi je suis un de
l'école a acheté des voitures usagées
oui parce que j'ai souvent eu des
voitures neuves que je m'attende peut
être fini par perdre du fou l'argent moi
j'ai arraché en 2014 ya trois ans elle
avait un ennemi d'usure à l'arrêt 30000
km de chez vous je m'attendais à me
coûter 28 1000 $ plus les taxes
ça c'est cher pour une voiture mais
quand je pense à toutes les économies
d'argent une voiture quand même une
excuse j'ai tout le siège chauffant tout
ce que tu peux imaginer il là quelqu'un
qui s'achète un us le c'est pas mal ça
les prix ou n'importe quelle voiture un
petit peu plus haut de gamme se sont
dits à risque pourtant tiré pour moi
mais moi je trouve assez important 2
pour l'écologie oui pis aussi c'est tout
c'est tout le débat écologique ça on a
fait tout une question de prix mais ses
soucis à la fin de la journée et
recycler ça coûte plus cher que tout
envoyé aux vidanges states et des choix
qu'on fait puis moi si je pouvais me le
permettre voilà je mets en oeuvre les
volts sur lequel je fais des kilomètres
j'ai fait ma tournée de spectacles au
complet avec ça je vais jusqu'au plafond
c'est ma main retour j'ai jamais eu
c'est comment tu sais moi et moi c'est
sûr qui aussitôt que j'ai les moyens
pour premièrement changer mon short ça
va être ça va être un show électrique /
/ / / ou hybrides
c'est charles mais c'est vrai que c'est
cher si tu veux voir les voitures neuves
mais dans les voitures d'occasion le tu
vois comme la mienne j'avais fait
évaluer le garage m'offrir française
mille dollars toujours du moins pour
acheter mon voyage une réduction
gouvernementales ont le jeu prend
spécialiste de ça mais je pense pas que
je l'avais parce que et il avait déjà eu
des usagers des lotos clarté d'un
particulier ou s'il est acheté d'un
concessionnaire qui va suivre les
bourgeois chevrolet à rodez mais si vous
cherchez des têtes d'affiché bourgeois
ne pense pas qu'ils ont besoin de world
invasion battle je pense que c'est le
centre de l'univers ça on va le
découvrir
copernic est un peu moins vrai
maintenant mais si souley une voiture
électrique c'est eux qui entendait parce
que les concessionnaires ont été supers
l'un en ont commandé une chevrolet tout
ça parce qu'ils avaient moins de
demandes
puis ils ont vraiment faire leur créneau
d'abord il y avait le janvier usagers
volts sur le terrain il n'y avait aucun
consensus en ce moment là aussi il y en
a peut-être une par jour avant au québec
une chèvre les vols pas tant pour des
voitures non mais vraiment c'était à
rawdon que ça se passait il connaissait
pour vrai à chaque année font genre de
petits salons genre des voitures
électriques dans leur concessionnaire
il pas juste des chevrolet lyon toutes
les marques dont l'affection vraiment
comme des pionniers
comble de la voiture électrique plus
être des mois pas s'acheter je me suis
fait mal parce que j'ai un ami qui s'est
acheté une tesla du sommet là je me suis
pris un essai routier chalet saillen
tesla trois hôtesses l'hôtesse l'a6 l'a3
si le modèle est à 30 ans à un gala au
mensonge à lyon ça pour que le monde
prenne des réservations tuque l'action
moncla c'est pas vrai elle coûte
tendwa bien là c'est celle que tu peux
recommander le kéké peau celle qui un
jour ouvré disponibles mettons sur une
tesla trois ans ce moment-là 74 mille
dollars
ça c'est le modèle économique mais je
pense que c'était 35 millions us pour
avec rien mais il n'existe pas ne peut
même pas la vie en plus parce que juste
pas sûr si encore ce modèle et en plus
il sera pas elle c'est vraiment la
chronique voiture elle ne sera pas
quatre roues motrices hockey et les
tests le sont les celi roue arrière qui
font pousser la voiture c'est pas comme
annaba donc dans l'hiver et la neige on
m'a dit que c'était une mauvaise idée de
ne pas prendre quatre roues motrices
je sais pour me dise pas que bref le
modèle à bas de gamme il sera jamais
vraiment une option au québec laisse pas
grave s'il ya des très bonnes autres et
gerba jean marc lalanne est ce que le
auto pilot il ta peau et jori
fonctionnement mais là j'ai essayé le
modèle performance qui est jean cent
mille dollars - celui que j'ai fait mais
le performance en plus six conducteurs
le camp que ça avec légal satellites
vont ramasser ça puait doit dormir au
volant il ya aussi le
c'est le assistant stationnement si je
fais toi et gadgets a pas besoin de ça
mes jumelles
quant à puis le gens sérieux j'ai arrêté
j'ai lâcher l'accélérateur et ça me fait
pas mais j'ai pas besoin que je serais
vous je me suis venu chez moi chaque
homme où est ce que je fais mon film je
veux cette voiture peut toujours dans ma
cour je me dis comme calmer sa faim
c'était juste une semaine
oui je parle à mes blagues comme quoi
que le hb je prends l'autobus maintenant
pour sauver de l'argent puis des taxis
j'économise pour m'acheter une tesla les
gens doivent cliquer mais publicité
commandé mes produits en lien un figuier
vous quoi pour m'aider à atteindre mon
drive acheté mon livre non sans blague
je pensais pas le voir une tesla et je
suis complètement irrationnel le dit
objet j'avais conduit celle de jean
marie de koninck
pour joséphine dans un livre pour passer
de québec la grossesse la marianne c'est
le modèle f clapper qui est pilote
automatique qui le tue mais donc dans ce
flashmob castor l'analyste chaput store
chez astaro sentent libres dans l'autre
voie la ja
j'arrivais à une courbe on était à 100
km h je ne les vaux l'argent la
propriété cela j'ai fauché valable mais
c'est vous encore au point que tu peux
dormir dedans tu pourrais pas ce que ça
à la reine dans le fond il également
combattu pour être à la règle mais tant
qu une lumière rouge
elle a 16 les shore en avant à l'arrêt
trait à l'art et rage contre lui c'est
le non seulement sur l'écran le tableau
de bord du modèle 3 de la route prévoir
exactement t ou dans la ligue et à des
silhouettes de tout ce qui aurait que
des caméras d'un porte des défauts
métier j'avais vraiment l'impression
d'être dans une voiture du futur
oui mais ça c'est le plus gros elle sera
montrée le faire le porte parole des
voitures électriques la voiture
électrique ce n'est pas la voiture du
futur de la voiture du présent au les
voitures électriques ou non disponibles
elles sont abordables elles sont fiables
elles ne tombent pas en panne ni vers
elles coûtent pas vraiment le bass ma
famille sommes assez vite sur un jeu
comme moi ça fait trois ans que je
refais des milliers de dollars en
essence pis ils disent le grand projet
de société
je le vis très emballée quand je parle
de l'électrification des transits à ce
que ces combats engagés
ai-je vraiment là je suis pour la
voiture électrique ne trouve ni un zoom
de pompes mais je sais pourquoi on ne
pourra encore la voiture les fric
partout c'est parce que le changement
fait peur la peur le changement c'est le
frein à la voiture électrique c'est pour
la technologie c'est pas les prix c'est
les gens achètent des voitures le à 60
mille dollars l'individu est des lieux
du monde qui ont de l'argent pour des
voitures vraiment la peur du changement
qui le vrai défi assure bellevret la
vraie chose à surmonter
puis ils veulent électrifié ces deux
projets des politiciens sont électrifiés
je n'ai fait poser une borne à mon
ancienne à part que c'est faire poser
une prise de sécheuse
c'est ce grand projet de société proposé
des prises de sécheuse facile c'est tout
le arrêté d'en faire un grand un mirage
on veut juste des prises électriques ve
et théorise de ces choses à l'extérieur
du bâtiment
si tous les témoins de plus de primes
plus de pilotes élevé témoin à charge et
non mais franchement c'est parce que des
fois on pensait qu'on plie électrifier
les transports mais ce pas dresser
vraiment c'est des prises de sécheuse
c'est tout un petit à l'échelle de
caisse qui est déjà été faite
collectivement dans société posé les
prix de ces je sais rien répond je sens
un aéroport comme la logistique là
dedans de crise on l'a fait mais je
pense à des prises de ce seul creuser
une écart creusé des tunnels souterrains
pour faire des métros alors une cité
souterraine complète là pour faire des
métros c'est des milliards et des
milliards poser des prix de ces choses
si ce n'est pas compliqué en tout cas
c'est vraiment un jour la ssii
et la voiture électrique puis je suis
surpris mais mes voisins dans mon nouvel
immeuble je leur disais que ça me
coûtait 12 $ d'électricité par un mois
pour recharger ma voiture est quand même
là c'est sûr qu'il n'y ait le système
vraiment 12 $ tout le monde aurait
dévoré clic
mais c'est le calcul pour ouvrir ces
sites et 38 c'est que ça coûte parmi ces
ag b c'est sûr qu'il ya différents
tarifs selon août branche parce que les
bornes publiques sont quand même une
question de vitesse de chargement petit
mais à la maison c'est certainement un
ami claiborne tesla
quand est un chartiste lâché que moi
j'ai effectué on est arrivé à
drummondville pour se charger eux au
retour
la borne tesla tesla faisait
gratuitement et charge gratuitement
doigt sur le modèle 3 ok ce n'est pas un
gars qui hante plus le soft une faille
du prix du modèle 3 il n'est pas
compatible avec le circuit électrique
que d'hydro-québec
tu dois te disais le super charger quand
même à savoir les skinheads ont vraiment
passionné de voitures électriques a
annoncé le blog roule electric.com et
c'est vous parce que avant de choisir ma
voiture s'est évidemment c'est pas tous
les jours que je dépense 28 mille
dollars soit pour une voiture de sa
première fois de ma vie je faisais ça
j'ai fait mes devoirs
c'est vraiment informés pour savoir
comment ça marche itx est aussi humaine
comme partout qu'on amène le changement
il faut avoir des arguments dans mon
immeuble était pas trop chaud à l'idée
que je me branche cotée genre et projets
politiques à chaque fois qu'on me le
borgne cac pas mais c'est faisable
l'attaquant gros autobus polly van nhon
manon manon
non mais enfin on ne voit on en a parlé
ça a été tellement froid et moi maccione
maintenant c'était malade un mot ce que
j'ai trouvé cool de ta vidéo avec manon
massé qui tu es parce que pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu qui que tu prennes l'hélium
puis vous parler politique et de
l'hélium allons marcher cette vidéo qui
a le mieux marché que dans cette année
son match c'est sûr mais sûrement mais
ce que j'aime c'est que tu mettais quand
même comment tu avais fait pour que
manon massé sur les dépôts les autres
expliquait que tu avais invité les eaux
et j'ai terminé ici non parce que
puissent aussi c'est important parce que
je pense qu'il est il chez que ma blonde
elle le fait à s'impliquer en politique
qui a s'est fait dire à quel point il
fallait pas qu'à prennent parti
nécessairement n'y a pas de règle et
j'aimerais leur ennemi liautaud bar
préféré américain tarot club des
supporters des lyrics la journaliste
d'avoir des activités voulait donner la
chance à tout le monde oui il ya juste
une personne qui le bris cette année
panique c'était la campagne chez qu'il y
avait des règles pour les personnes qui
suivaient les les autobus en campagne
les médias précisent également qu'ils
ont pas le droit non plus de se faire
comme je suis après pas faire payer une
chambre d'hôtel le ton face à ces
camions vers l'autobus la personne les
médias traditionnels sont emparés le
tube mais en fait on peut le comprendre
aussi pourquoi un peu de poids deux
mesures de nouvelles qui roule à qui
j'envoie des crises actuellement c'est
ça la force et sa foi du tout le même
et le même contexte de travail mais je
comprends aussi une espèce de jalousie
la ville parce que je pense que ça va
falloir soit adressée pour une prochaine
campagne française de coca il va falloir
qu'ils admis qu'il soit mis aux classes
étaient floutés les règles et
naturellement on portrait des idées d'un
parti si nous impliquer autrement que
dans une campagne électorale
fred bastien qui a interviewé philippe
couillard et y posait mais j'étais très
curieux d'entendre le 5 mars qui parlait
de youtube a ensuite subi fait
dépouilleurs et 18 février soit un enjeu
que je connais mal l'important que vous
impliquer à l'année longue
getty pour nous tenir au courant de ça
et là ma n'est pas nouveau et youtube
lyon c'est des centaines de milliers de
dollars qui sont distribués dans le
québec sur machine kills ou non mais il
ya quand même c'est un joueur important
c'est pas nous
le pendant combien d'années on peut dire
c'est de la nouveauté avant d'être
complètement décalé complètement décalé
en ce moment - pis c'est des
institutions les partis politiques et
les autres c'est l'assaut des contrôles
ne sont pas intéressés moi j'ai voulu
aller les rencontrer ils retournent pas
mais à perdre j'ai voulu aller m'asseoir
avec les normes canadiennes de la
publicité pour les sensibiliser à on
n'est pas tous membres de goji oudin
slingshot d'une agence qui appartient un
gros groupe média des indépendants sur
le web en une réalité qui est différente
d'une grande agence y jouent ils sont
pas intéressés à manille cebu dois de
dire qu'on s'implique mais aussi faux
que de l'eau bord acte et je pense que
les politiciens s'ils veulent que les
influenceurs jouer avec urbaine à amman
il faut pour ce soit juste parce qu'une
élection puis mais oui c'est vrai je me
saoule à voir tout le monde heureux
j'aurais aimé savoir les quatre chefs
sont marchands et puis dans le fond je
suis jean françois lisée avait dit
peut-être justement il parlait ouais
mais ça c'était sa stratégie de laisser
la porte ouverte sans jamais vraiment la
ferme et août
il peut pas dire que dit non moi je l'
ai vu comme ça parce qu'en fait j'ai été
un petit peu quand même un temps moi je
trouvais que ma chaîne youtube j'ai
certaines vidéos et comme ma vidéo job
de papa presque un millier un demi
million de clicks dessus j'ai vu fait
les prieurs j'ai vu plein d'autres chefs
à la des émissions comme le beau
dimanche à radio-canada jésus aux
échanges et ce bon j'ai dévalé en pleine
émission qui ont des cotes d'écouté
inférieur à ma chaîne youtube certain
flou il ya beaucoup dû beaucoup
d'émissions qui ont fait fureur sur
youtube un des mets pas toutes les
semaines et j'en ai des vidéos qui ont
moins de vue j'en ai qui marche bien
mais quand ça marche
les vues sont là parce que je me disais
bon moi je prends ma démarche de youtube
heures au sérieux je le fais avec
professionnalisme j'ai un respect sans
fin pour les abonnés jeu pour moi c'est
la relation avec les abonnés de la chose
la plus précieuse à conserver parce que
c'est les seuls qui me choisissent ils
pas une programmation qui met de l'avant
je le fais avec sérieux j'ai envie que
si je fais une invitation chef de
politiques et des chefs de partis je
veux qu'ils apprennent mon invitation
aussi sérieusement que si j'étais une
émission de télé donc je veux les chefs
chez moi voyons tous essayé que j'aille
dans leur autobus que gérard collomb
comme stan bowman cd rom se moquer moi
c'est un joueur qu'on fait on va dire
mais pas ma première idée de jeu correct
j'en ai proposé une autre si y'avait que
je n'ai pas fermé beaucoup ont fait se
souvient même à saillon pas de curieuses
décoller première des mois je veux qu'on
fasse le jeu marche mais ceci n'était
pas dans mes débuts chez d'embarquer sur
tous les gens que l'expo la vidéo ils
voient ça inspire t on dans le journal
keira qui je comprenais l'enjeu fax pour
ça que j'ai proposé autre chose
mais fallait que je propose une idée qui
se tourner rapidement qu'ils étaient
quand même équitable entre jeu le point
des bois des passages vous lire puis un
truc qui demandent aucune préparation
dans une campagne vont pas se préparer
trois jours pour venir faire régner sur
ma chaîne fait qu on oublie tout ce qui
est prestations musicales août
m j'ai mis des nombreux conflits king on
peut pas faire ça que j'ai proposé les
lieux et des cinq communes distinctes
premières sont prend de l'hélium est là
quand c'est juste mon nom qui lui
seraient faites un vidéo & click a tout
fait quatre vidéos je refais une avec
les quatre avec un teint qui table
c'était d'y nommer pitch tout se fait
que moins jusqu'à la fin il était comme
intéressé pour intéresser mais là moi
j'avais dit un calendrier de production
je voulais pas sortir ce après la
campagne électorale ces cinq hommes +
rapport avec un bref la seule qui a dit
oui c'est l'équipe de mon mari a bien
fait comme enrique un soc 12 est à 200
milles vue vous entendu parlé le
lendemain au delà de ça a été reprise
dans la télé oui si ça mais c'est un bon
pari à faire pisser c'est le seul parti
qui vous paraît le petit gabriel
nadeau-dubois yves venu au podcast ici
le deuxième invité qu'on a reçue le 3
mai il m'avait proposé gabriel aussi ok
et moi j'insiste et d'avoir manon massé
parce que je trouvais que craignent à
juste une fille campagne on va là m'ont
très vite qu'il est venu ici il a
accepté ci n'a plus grand chose à
montrer
il n'y a aucun pas de casque et est sûre
si le site est juste une idée il pas de
carte à ce moment là le pour l'approcher
pied zioui taxi s'est pris un méchant
guest mais ils y ont pris les guest des
réseaux sociaux puis clairement ça joue
en leur faveur
il y avait une équipe très jeune aussi
dans l'autobus le les gens qui sont
venus chez moi
la vieille garde mais l'attaché de
presse à abriel tant mieux pour eux
mapping parce que j'ai trouvé place dans
le fait que
je me demande soit réfugié de façon
catégorique c'est que moi je suis je
suis très respectueux des abonnés mais
je suis encore plus des des invités sur
ma chaîne il est arrivé mais l'as far en
quatre ans une mission que le tournage
on jase ya plein d'affaires j'aurais pu
publier quel monde aurait eu l'air fou
pour moi c'est important que situé sur
ma chaîne qui va pouvoir voir la vidéo
peut être déçu d'être venu tg j'en dis
que tu sois content de montage est
bafouée je le coupe et et je veux que
tout le monde paraissent bien effectué
chaque homme déçu comme bâton à liszt et
schumann
mais non c est comme des succès sachant
de tout le respect que j'ai pour les
invités qui vient sur ma chaîne dès que
l'on soit comme sur les gardes j'allais
les maîtres hambourg mais je pense que
ça lui a tendrement plus par rapport aux
médias que à la personne j'ai
l'impression qu'ils disent et encore
maintenant le titre une conversation est
en conversion mon père le plus c'est
encore les j'avais amélioré faut pas que
tu mettes telles affaires sur internet
parce que le volet ça peut faire le
[Rires]
meilleur qu'un clash de génération c'est
ce exact mettez pendant combien parce
que tu te tais oui à une méconnaissance
du média tu sommet encore un week-end
dans le cahier pose de la presse dame
encore un article pour expliquer c'est
quoi des influenceurs mélomanes n'ont
pas compris combien de temps on va le
répéter qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
côtoyer ou tout bien
il ya eu un article au lancement de mon
livre on
normalement dans l'ensemble ils vont
perdurer mais il y avait deux lignes sur
mon livre après ça c'était les 50
grandes grues une pme verdi qui fait des
pubs les placements de produits piquant
mais c'est quoi le rapport
on parle dans mon livre où on est venu à
décortiquer les sais pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui y jouent bas viennent
pas à toi malgré toi c'est qu'ils
encaissent internet puis full tilt
connect du fauteuil sur youtube puis
c'est pas comme c'est l'habitude des
québécois depuis des années depuis 50
ans des cta télévision de seppi qui le
les personnes que tu vas voir ils sont à
ta tv c'est pas vraiment choisi maison
le petit riode et a choisi mais t'avais
maintenant cinquante cinq options c'est
sale et chante en même temps possible
l'internet cia plus le pôle efforts ou
la démarche de suivre quelqu'un parce
que tu as choisie mais en même temps ça
fonctionne vous en faire c'est justement
parce que le public se choisit une
personne d'autre qui a violé deux
maintenant c'est comme étant il ya deux
ans nuage aurait dit sur youtube c'est
vraiment pour que les gens choisissent
pithiviers qui s'abonnent maintenant
faut que youtube me mettre dans
l'accueil plus en plus on consulte puis
moi le premier mon anglais abonnements
chez de moins en moins bien dedans je
regarde l'accueil les suggérer mais des
fois je laisse rouler youtube c'est
youtube décède à ma place la prochaine
vidéo ses yeux il ya de plus en plus une
programmation sa rampe est moins
compliqué mais parce qu'elle est
extrêmement personnalisé moi c'est sûr
mais il y en a eu un sens plus la main
de youtube le traverse hull c'est moins
et à 100 milles à l'heure si j'avais
commencé une série de blogs qui était je
cherche ma nouvelle maison parce que
j'étais en processus de déménagement
comment je passe une maison j'ai acheté
un condo mais je suis pris dans les mots
climat nouvelle maison des maisons non
mais c'est que je décore ma nouvelle
maison mais c'est pas de ma maison c'est
un condo mais je peux plus sortir des
mots clés que ça continue d'être acquis
remporté aux abonnés qui ont vu que
cherche une nouvelle maison s'est
vraiment rendu le choix des mots le
et le choix des mots clés le choix des
tags web s adonneraient en fait c'est
qu'en ce moment je trouve que youtube
baisse assez la critique depuis le long
temps youtube pénalise la créativité
si tu fais une idée qui est complètement
original à vos partys dans le krach a va
tomber dans cracks
c'est un concept qui a été fait par un
autre qui est pogné le style fait ça va
marcher plus web itunes mais atteint à
savoir et voyez idéalement ce soit juste
une copie houeillès meilleur florman
programmation à chaque fois je fais de
la télé me dit ce genre et il me
présente au public des télécoms si
regardez polio tout je connaissais le
même monde et vous y regarde la télé et
je vous dis lyon l'internet aussi mais
l'inversé moins vrai c'est le mans qui
regardent youtube en garde sur ma tv un
peu le monde rigole la tva ne regarde
pratiquement pouilloux tous mes frères
et moi me parler d'occupation du pia
regarde la télé cet été sur nouveauté
aussi continuer sur damas mais quand
même position télé ouais mais toute la
structure télé suite
ilaria ce jour que c'est le mot je me
demande beaucoup quel intérêt à un
public plus jeune dans la majorité des
émissions qu'on voit qu'on a la
télévision parce que c'est pas du tout
la cible et quand on regarde mettons
tout le monde en parle
l'âge moyen des invités et ses sources
de 18 20 ans de la moyenne est rarement
au bout de cinquante ans les invités
juste par semaine
y'a jamais plus qu'un invité en bas de
40 ans tout le monde en parle pour une
émission qui vise la bien vivre du monde
pour leur public c'est comme ça qu'ils
réfléchissent là
c'est normal mais est-ce que tu attires
les jeunes dresser com est-ce qu'il faut
que tu fasses est ce que les jeunes
regardent pas la télé ou la télé et qui
en premier par un service yeux qui fait
le s'éloigner ouais tu sais que la main
mais sûrement et met un pied dans la
tombe
aussi parce qu'elle en est mais si
j'avais un pote en public c'est aussi
pour la terrible comme rejoindre des
gens parce que là il ya comme toute
nouvelle vague de gens que les jeunes
suivent conduit en hissant filtration
mais il ya vraiment honte était de
tellines des choses que tu faisais que
tu peux pas dire s'il ya quand même ça
puisse régner au trix n'existe pas il
existe il ya vraiment un ton il me
défoncer des entrevues plongeant
cependant à cause de l'émission commence
vraiment un temps de télé qui on n'est
pas habitué à ce que michael disait
chômage passe le regard des atouts monde
en parle dimanche passé bien sûr que tu
manges penser qu'un coup de chance de
sortir mais mais c'est parce qu'ils y
baile séguy acquis qu'ils y est
il cite l'enfant il dit j'aime pas
qu'elle ait un fils que lui un podcast
m'accorder le plus gros podcast au
québec ça s'écoute qui parlait de moi
d'ailleurs au podcast c'est le gars qui
boit du vin
le plaignant qui avait pas de
commanditaires pour son efficace
moi j'en ai c'est quoi ces coûts tu
commences ta non non ça j'ai jamais de
suspendre venir sur mac
ah oui mais comment ça mais j'en ai
plein à toutes les machines mais c'est
pas céder comme le gie coca cola qui est
un de mes grands clients je sais de quel
loto québec
j'ai bientôt ce que d'autres estimations
soit moins le temps que ça ne va pas
mais comment ça marche et ce qui est
parce que madame ai je tort qu'elles
citi dit j'aime ici tu m'accordes les
guillemets j'aime pas quand les invités
viendront pas de casse puis il parle
comme qui parle à tout le monde en parle
c'est ça qui luttent en guise ici qu est
ce que tu penses que nos invités
viennent ici nous mentent puis le mardi
ce soir à la télé c'est comme ça qu'elle
a ici un petit peu ce qu'on veux pisser
rock
tivo peut-être avoir un commentaire de
trop personnes fauchées mais ça s'est
fini c'est fini le pied mais oui très
haut niveau ce n'est pas contre mais si
on n'est pas extrême mais c'est
tellement grand public mais peu à côté
le titre est romancé mais aussi ses
caisses carrière avec la télé c'est que
c'était un travail d équipe et moi au
début je peux dire mais la faire mais je
peux pas vraiment remettre en question
les choix de d'occupation par cathy
c'est le travail des collègues
si je peux pas commencer à bâcher je
peux pas croire qu'ils ont fait ici on
fait autant l'éloge de rodez que la
critique d'audubon couple de faucons
critique mais c'est vrai qu'à la télé on
a un temps des fois qu'ils aient pas
100% dessus mais aussi un parce que la
force et que j'ai l'impression sur le
web les publics et fo un petit peu plus
futés parce qu'ils sont plus concentrés
c'est la télé a joui punk trois phrases
qui font autre chose en même temps c'est
vrai que des fois ils lisent moins bien
dans les zones grises quapla
soudainement il faut l'intention de
seillon juste retenu leboutou et c'est
un peu cet effet la fifa que je peux
comprendre pourquoi quand on a des fois
qu'ils ont comme la langue de bois
ils vont adhérer et puis il est toujours
des chèques lundi des lettres ouvertes
et des réponses à un tel les atomes on
n'en parle pas
télévision et au plus juste la
télévision c'est ça qui est fort
heureusement pu la télévision même
encore moi j'ai même si c'était comme
j'ai de moins en moins des bas de 3 mais
je rêve de moins en moins de faire la
télévision c'est sûr que c'est un beau
projet télé j'aimerais c'est y aller
parce que beaucoup de trucs à la
télévision que j'aime beaucoup j'aime
l'idée qu'un public
j'aime l'idée que le mans son beau-fils
force a dû finalement se fait coiffer
son mât qui y ont choisi leur tenue il
ya un spectacle à la télé sur youtube on
a moins sûr c'est le côté préparez vous
le plus j'aime ce côté là date est
licite appel pour animer une nouvelle
version de la fureur mais tonton je
pense pas pour l'instant
non mais c'est ainsi qu'il a pu avec bel
qst il a fait ça arrivera au pôle mais
je suis pas assez bon en musique contre
ici pour moi que ça prend pour ceux en
plus je reste bien trop stressé devant
public un jeu j'en parle à voix haute je
trouve à dire ça mais dans ces boues qui
est too soon pour ramener les recettes
pompette t on s'entend que je pense pas
que ce serait et riscle qu'il serait non
non non c'est sûr ça c'est tout sur une
bourse us mais c'est trop saoul pour
ramener parce que je ne le ferai pas à
la télé mais il je suis vraiment sept
ans à la recherche de formes que je veux
adapté pour youtube ou pour nouveau pour
autre que je regarde tout ce qu'ils sont
en forme en pis c'est le mot juste de
montfort mots qui s'impliquent pas sa
fille nina de la contreverse mais la
forme est encore bon tu sais que je me
disais tu trop tôt pour que moi j'essaye
de les ramener
ne restent pas faire trop comparer avec
sa maman me compare déjà fugué puis je
parle plus je le sais c'est facile de
nous comparer deux personnes geek parle
que sont le lundi peter on n'allait pas
sans peiner services par exemple je vous
je ne suis pas parti mais c'est vieux je
pense pas car un scandale sur moi je les
juge pas mais je ne sais pas c'est trop
tôt maintenant leur jardin l'eau et
accepter les recettes pompes et je
promets un poil mais qu'il faudrait
changer un petit peu le concept mais nos
forces dans le formule go je l'achèterai
a maintenant le concept tel quel
telle quelle recette on perd avec p m
je sais pas vraiment brainstormer j'en
parle parce que honnêtement j'y crois
pas que ça va arriver là sinon je
garderai ça pour moi mais mon feeling
sexy
il y aurait définitivement rembourser ce
prêt serait josé une bonne idée quand
mon inspection sur un portail qui
épaulent youtube parce qu'il n'ya pas
tant de trafic la supra d'origine à la
thrombose ouais on le reverra du murmure
après parce que ça comparé way
puis la formule est bonne les gens vont
rester parce que je sais pas je pourrais
je pense que moi je pense que c'est une
bonne idée parce que c'est une bonne
dépense talent jeannette after he was
hickstead cette affaire
égoutter non mais en plus ça veut pas
dire que l'on me permettrai de le faire
mais je crois sa partie avec seulement
depuis maintenant ça a été racheté par
mais en fait je ne sais pas au niveau du
droit d'auteur je sais que tu quand tu
as une idée je pense que tu loues ton
idée un produit par marc sans soudure
est toujours l'auteur
la musique c'est très prisé par des
droits d'auteur même si j'ai passé
différents dit la voix de sa dépend de
comment c'est parti au début mais le
concept comme tel a été acheté par media
orange qui a racheté toutes les
productions qu'avait de salvail and co
et là ça a été racheté par entourage qui
produit les émissions de messmer du bac
c'est là qu'il faudrait que je pense que
si je le faisais en web
j'aurais pas des vedettes de tellines
j'aurais dû monde du web c'est ce qu'ils
font ce qu'on veux que le monde vienne
seghouane moins chez propre texte car
une fois de temps en temps le genre est
facile de varier un petit peu oui c'est
une des clientes ait si vous connaissez
d'autres le font parce que moi j'ai vu
que ça avait été fait en france en
version adaptée et en faire à cette
pompe est sur youtube avec monsieur
poulpe par match pour un format qui on
peut acheter mes meilleurs php les
vidéos de recettes aux sélections des
recettes et du temps perdu en bois de
l'alcool mais on n'est pas bon
c'est quelque chose c'est clair mais on
faire des vidéoclips bate
j'ai encore je me prête au jeu des fois
le de faire un petit clic button et
ligue b
mais non j'aime pas c'est mal parti
complètement all-in clique de mon blog
qui sortent entoure le ser ont compris
mon nouveau siège en option dans mes
mains et mes pas m'ont chine ces jeux
l'étude trouvait dans un la fondation
mira
ce qui est important quand tu fais un
clic bates est de le désamorcer dans le
début de ta vidéo comme ça les gens
comme toi ta clique bêtes sont pas
choqués jusqu'à qui est important mais
ça devient qu'elle soit une blague je
peux peut-être c'est roger trop et j'ai
pas pu cacher sortie daudet j'ai trop vu
déclic band 2 à prendre on doit narcisse
épidémie enfants beaucoup des webzines
du clan des esprits tout ce monde des
stars monde de star c'est ça mon install
d'affaires c'est un monde de star le
j'avais jamais dit c'est la seule fois
de ma vie que j'ai fait ça il y avait
écrit un truc j'ai pris mon téléphone
j'ai dix ans je me rachète la publicité
sur mon dos tu as pris mon transférant
quelqu'un d'important c'est quoi cela
c'est de crier au téléphone mais il y
avait qu il y avait volé ma vidéo il y
avait mis ma vidéo avec joey scarpellino
qu on respirait des ballons à l'hélium
encore y avait pris ma vidéo qui
hébergeait dans l'arc les yeux mais on
leur met l'art propre publicité puis
avait repris ma face pour mettre juste
jolie a un talent trucs et ja a pris la
tête en friche donne une heure pour
retirer votre vidéo sinon en avoir une
lettre de mon avocat bla bla bla était
vraiment bonne
le monsieur ont fait tourner en direct
de leur dire qu'ils avaient une
chronique
c'est la seule fois de l'enlever
mais jamais fait cela dans leur monde
ayrton était de rigueur dans leur
sous-sol à candiac
je savais aussi que j'appelais mais non
c'est la seule fois que j'ai fait toute
ma vie je peux pas croire j'ai fait ça
c'est mal à tous devrait faire plus ben
ali les personnes qui parlent de moins
fatigante et alliés savent la clé on va
chez big society rochelle reçoit plus de
celle du député match comme moi
j'aimerais qu'on parle de toi de ton
auto biographie c'est la bio dégradable
numéro la mise en contexte du rocher
première nationale on a la biographie de
pl tous vos bas n'était qui s'activent
loana qui sortent heaven wii puis suite
à ses yeux ben je suis pas suite ne
ferment jamais eu beaucoup de tomber la
fille écrit par plusieurs personnalités
du web entre autres dans la dernière
année
et tout ça à culminée à un article mais
j'ai à dire que c'est la faute de la
prime ou sur cet article
c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait donc
l'article de sophie durocher qui disait
qu'il y avait des pays à la place à des
filles ou des récits biodégradables en
fuite puis pipi a fait une vidéo en
réponse à ceux à temps mais faut dire qu
est ce qu a dit non mais tu es beaucoup
en question là
légitimité de ces des gens plus jeunes
d'écrire des livres qui ont une saveur
biographie puis à parler de mon livre
comme parce que moi j'ai toujours dit
que ce n'est pas une biographie puis
honnêtement dans mon livre d'autres
robben était si vous cherchez une
biographie vous allez être déçus c'est
paul urgent en trois chapitres qui sont
à savoir biographique qui mena mans je
parle de mes histoires c'est pas de la
fiction ce pas une autofiction jodie
déjà un chapitre sur le coming out un
chapitre sur partir en appart mais j'ai
des pages sur comment manger des pâtes
tout les soirs sans cette année j'ai des
pages sur les types de gosse sur tender
ya plein de sujets qui sont pas des
biographies fac j'ai dit que c'était pas
une biographie depuis le début dans les
entrevues que je pense que sophie
durocher chercher des exemples pour
appuyer son son sa prémisse qui était il
ya trop de gens écrivent des biographies
qui ont pas des parcours suffisant pour
ça on a tout à perdre biographie de
youtube heures à tomber sur ce qu'ils
achetaient devenue une exemple puis amap
redwood
c'est une biographie 1 avec du sud
vraiment ça cherche une biographie le i
mank qu'il ya tellement de trous en plus
ce serait difficilement aux tories comme
biographie parce que j'ai fait un choix
de choses à dire et à ne pas dire des
sports une biographe loquidy maison
tomber' moi aussi j'aurai des enfants
doivent apprendre dans l'île a serait
déçu si c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
bref j avais répondu dans une vidéo
parce que le lui et oui je le sais
qu'elle le lui rendre a dit j'aimerais
penser qu'elle risque
moi je pensais qu'on parlait ça l'avait
vu mon blog ou lui un truc à propre ma
réponse mais je pense pas qu'elle le lui
juste à la nommait 5,6 truc à lui vu
alors vu ta vidéo paix est invité à son
émission à battre avec elle plutôt bon
et lui a dit non pourquoi ben je voyais
pas à quoi ça servait un fait parce que
je
je réalise à arrêter comme l'émission de
quelqu'un d'autre ou il ya une vraie
conversation match comme à vaujours
traduire la même affaire qu'on s'est dit
champ texte est comme nourrir une
tempête dans un verre d'eau
je voyais pas trop où ça allait aller en
plus pour quelqu'un que jaillit peuvent
probablement car à la fin on aurait ri
on aurait eu une belle entrevue puis
s'arrête comme dit lui mon propos parce
que j'ai pas quelqu'un qui va confronter
pas les bras croisés et puis je peux
même facture que j'aime à pattes rouges
je voyais pas le but puis j'ai décidé
que j'allais juste comme vous j'ai
l'impression c1 rooney sol si je la
connais pas pu peut-être dans le change
peut-être conspirationnistes mais j'ai
l'impression c'est sa stratégie un peu
le tir de piquer un peu à gauche à
droite attend de voir qui va répondre et
à prendre les réponses pileux escalader
comme secret des comptes revient et je
pense aussi c'est quand même un défi de
trouver un sujet par jour qui passe ici
pas certain que ça l'empêchent de dormir
que holly prime au sort des biographies
là je pense que mes séjours caire mais
master même pas son texte qui me
dérangeait c'était le temps qu'il
déconne c'est sage explique dans ma
vidéo où j'y réponds pendant jean-damien
ses bienfaits le texte est arrêté à
chaque phrase mais c'est que j'aï seule
espèce attitude qui dit aux jeunes
arrêtés de ces deux fins du projet est
trop jeune pour part des choses
c'est tout en soit ça où les jeunes font
rien cissé jamais comme un hic c'est
beau de voir les jeunes font c'est pia
lépi et moi j'ai écrit le livre je les
10000 fois j'ai fait ce projet là parce
que pour moi ça représente un défi mais
pour moi le fait de relever un défi puis
essayer quelque chose pour la première
fois ce une raison suffisante de
l'essayer c'est tout ça finit là ya pas
plus de pression que ça puis c'est sur
mon message fac de voir quelqu'un venir
dire aux gens vous êtes trop jeunes que
si tu veux dire quant aux 25 ans à ce
propos ouais je t'ai canards oies et
puis en ce que je sache assure journée
logique sommes pris à la caméra j'ai
répondu chez jamais ça mais moi ce qui
me dérangeait le plus dans son article
penser que la désirante à vider ou 90 me
dérangeait c'était cheveux sécu
du thé respectives c'est dans son
article ces quinquas qu'à la fin je
n'avais plus la formulation exacte mais
à la fin a dit pilar vous irez parler
aux auteurs qui sont au sol entre qui
font tout pour cette prochaine les
primes on faisait une blague fait c'est
que sur son livre il ya un fusil avec
une bouteille de shampoing cinq pattes
et j'espère que quand même ballot salon
se livrent ils vont moins avoir la
décence de partage et de champagne avec
les vrais auteurs mais aussi un petit 4
faisait une blague sur le fixe y avait
sur sa cover de lits primo mais sa
blague était et est à double tranchant
parce que même en profiter pour faire
une espèce de pointe comme de quoi parce
que t'es pas un auteur qui a été pauvre
en rue à écrire d'aider des romains avec
son arme puis qu'à cause de ce dépôt
l'un des auteurs c'est que non mais
j'estimais cité avant mais a traduit
quelque chose qui existe pour vrai je le
dis aussi dans la vidéo le talent
l'émission de mario rossi ni à radio
canada 3 et d'influenceurs puis comme un
conte et la publicité cachée mais bon
j'ai dit c'est sûr que les youtube arc
et des influenceurs on a un problème
d'image auprès de ceux qui nous suivent
pas mais on est souvent vue de haut on
est tout le temps ce qu'on fait c'est
pas crédible ces boîtes chui sai on est
tout le temps sopi scaler 10 par rapport
au fait qu'on n'ait pas des vrais
auteurs c'est un petit peu ce qu'a dit
mais je sais ça représente vraiment le
pignon de bourrache exemple même pas
juste pour les autres on n'est pas des
vrais créateurs moyens on parle de nous
dans nos chambres sur youtube et on note
vraiment un problème d'image sur
internet je sais pas comment corps c'est
sûr mais on a un problème d'image pied à
la halle le dit mais je lave entendu
aussi quand j'ai sorti mon livre je vais
être au salon du livre viendrait me voir
là je vais à côté des youtuber qui ont
écrit des livres sur un coin de table
ces jeux
esseulé entendu mais ce discours lors
des recherches et de télé aussi je me
suis pas fait j'ai des amis moi quand
j'ai participé chaîne et la moquerie des
bureaux de rechercher des ressources et
c'est ça qui demande l aipis alim fois
l'eau et il se prend pas pour de la
merde y'a comme si d'un côté
autoproclamés qui dérange mélisande
municipal avait la même frustration des
américains puis juste pourquoi
mais pour venir à se figer par appareil
lg sans âge tout lampes les gens me
l'ont reproché mais c'était juste pour
lui rendre la monnaie unique m'a jamais
défendre soft est clairement parce que
je t'aime havre ac 2-2 qui à part les
quelques 10 sont en jeu tout le monde
sait le lac à la fois le ministre en
droit ces canaux mélange de tout le
monde comme une raison de dévaluer la
personne ans ou est-ce pour ça que dans
ma vidéo que les titres i en plus chère
matrix têtes raides
ça s'est vraiment battu de ma part je
sais pas ça le 6 mai son ange est très
difficile à trouver sur internet depuis
quelques mois je les mets dans le titre
pourrait être tout le monde le trouve
vraiment mauvais mais c'est comme est
venu chercher georges et je fais pas ça
dans virgin post de la rancoeur de
madness parce qu'il était et évoque une
fiente ton l'épisode coin du financier
de quoi être fier de faire de quang nam
période quoi être fier de vouloir faire
le meilleur qu'on peut tout le temps
puisque longtemps ce qui est beau ce qui
le lisent ça aucun moment et comme on ne
peut pas savoir le travail que cette
fois un livre comme je dis tout le temps
aux gens qui veulent faire un livre qui
pensent maintenant que c'est un travail
je fais tout moi trou puis ça a été
comme je suis impliqué et je ferai mais
je vraiment pas envie de défendre mon
livre parce que c'est pas mon genre
d'être comme je haïs vaut la peine
il vaut la peine pour moi ça s'est passé
c'est que c'est vrai quand il mais je
veux j'ai choisi le choix des potes du
papier je t'en aller voir des
échantillons c'est moi qui voulais une
couverture rigide
j'ai demandé plein de couleurs j'ai un
lieu rien que j'ai peur que pour
montceau la police de caractère est
approuvée au départ la dent pour des
pages très jeune je voulais du bleu il
ya j'étais là dans les détails de ces
propos ching
fin de la parenthèse de livres parce que
j'ai sens pas que j'aie elle défend nom
exact ce qui est drôle d'annoncé
qu'est ce fils d'yves rocher chronique à
l'hôte à la peau une ligne directrice de
penser à vous dire quelque chose
c'est l'homme et on espère elithis
désigner les vrais auteurs qui en 300
copies versus lit mais voulait pas si
longtemps c'était le gala des cinémas
québécois bst est comme on sait bien
c'est juste les films que personne n'a
vu que sont récompensés et puis les
films que le modem voit alors un un dico
ce pas contradictoire c'est juste attire
un peu sur tout ce qui bouge à gauche à
droite dit la tante de sérieux de ces
mêmes papara par ailleurs c'est par
rapport à l'ensemble des chroniqueurs de
pignons totalement être dur comme de se
lever le matin de trouver un sujet qui
divise le créer un petit tempête puis
l'algérie jusqu'à la fin de la soirée
une petite couche le lendemain c'est
quoi mon sujet sérieux régime commun pas
bravo donc à tenir ce sommet que moi je
réagis comme une dépression fouille de
la négative vous donnez qu'elle n'a pas
pas de dire des choses il y avait du
monde pour abandonner le jeu demande non
pis je pense que rien quand une tribune
comme celle qu'elle ne les commente rien
pour te dérange et surtout pas moi qui
fais la roche qui me tourner vers son
toupet je trouve
non mais sérieux tout bottes si ton
succès tilt sur toute personne qui te
décides et patata chaîne qu'il faisait
en faisant des joueurs ont des trucs qui
le fon positif pour un genre en attaque
en personne ou anti justin justin fait
tant de quoi de fon par est en toi même
qui ça marche et si tu es el jdir son
succès je les connais peu pitié et
souvent perspicaces mais si tout le
temps un petit peu sur le dos les autres
c'est parce que le sait rien qu'on
traverse mais j'en ai mon gré rajouter
moyen d'un talent de toujours mettre le
doigt sur ce qui pour quand même lui
donner ça mais
et j'ai commencé vraiment monde et
boisset tambay mons 3 go en fait dans
youtube
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
d'obtenir l'attention qu'il ait vu avec
du contenu quand dans de la candeur de
la positivité du oui c'est un bonne
humeur
c'est certain que si tu fais du drame
mode si je sais ma vie j'ai fait un blog
et qui était genre et d'un blog
quotidien
je me rappelle pas du tout mais il ya eu
jean 11 mai de vue c'était la vidéo qui
suivait celle où il y avait une
controverse avec sophie durocher qui à
l'état 44000 moi j'ai quatre fois plus
de vue dans l'axé derrière youtube
j'ai pas changé en moi je personnes en
tout simple mais ouais je sais pas et
j'ai fait mais c'est vraiment un métier
tuent des gens tu fais ton succès le
mais pour moi le succès le cpo et c'est
pas acquis dans la durée comme j'ai
gagné le prix le dpcp gens de la fausse
humilité lui demandera n'importe qui a
chanté parlé quand on me donnait le
titre d'influenceurs de l'année le
chouchou des québécois et j'ai pour cela
comme un honneur je reçois comme une
pression de leur prouver que je méritais
c'est beaucoup plus à mon attitude gens
par rapport à ça jaillit sur savoir des
prix de jusqu'au merci pour enfin c'est
ce qui est délicat et qu'il veut pour
janvier j'aime pas sans savoir des prix
parce que c'est comme des gens veulent
c'est comme dire applaudi si mon emploi
c'est le public quand il va l'applaudir
c'est vraiment ça se fait pas rire
applaudir sais pas où tu es le public
qui veut dire quelque chose c'est flou
sur le respecte aussi qui a envie
d'applaudir mai
gilles vit mal avec les prix j'aime pas
faire savoir j'ai compris que je suis
comme neutre par rapport à ça c'est les
cent mille abonnés qui me dérange pas
mais tout le reste on dirait que c'est
subjectif je dis pas bien avec ça qu'on
va savoir dans mettons le tout ce que
j'ai fait qu'on considère comme être des
succès dans trois ans n'y a plus
personne qui écoute ça valait quoi c'est
quelque chose qu'on dit des influences
aussi ouest je fais de toi est ce le ca
du repos de la nand en design seront
pilotes
c'est quelque chose qu'on attend je
l'attends douteux mais j'ai tendance à
le croire aussi
j'ai trop c'est pour moi le plus
m'empêche de dormir la nuit de savoir
qu'est ce qui fait que je reste
pertinent que je peux en train dé ce qui
les autres en ce moment qui est bon et
ce genre le bon s'agirait maintenant
qu'est-ce qui peut un qu'est ce qui fait
que je peux continuer dans l'air du
temps parce que ses matons patrice
l'écuyer le teint grand talent
d'animateur mais qu'est ce qui fait que
c'est patrice l'écuyer c'est parce que
yo duré pendant toutes ces années puis
tour encore avec moi c'est sur mon jeu
dans la durée - jeu peau et mais oui je
pense que beaucoup ici il ya beaucoup de
gens que leur qui fait qu'on l'ait
suisse et qui sont extrêmement beau pays
des bons il y en a tout le temps d'autre
si ce corps est d'être beau pays de
jouer là-dessus cesser définitivement
définitivement un avantage d'être beau
dans les rues comme ph
oui voilà jeudi c'est elle est non mais
dans le sens que je les fasse comme oui
c'est beau de faire un métier d'être
très suivie sur instagram sera un truc
purement esthétique mais il y en aura
puis un autre puis en aura d'autres des
plus gérer la beauté et la jeunesse et
la beauté ça vaut souvent ensemble
et j'aime ça pensez qu'il faut avoir une
démarche un petit peu plus profond
respect doit être interchangeables en
même temps s'il y en a qui font des
carrières complètes surtout le fait que
son body et on voit plus de talent que
d'autres fake tchéquie pour dire ça mais
moi je pense que tout ce qui est des
influenceurs les créateurs contenu cc2
décret une une unicité quitté propre
c'est toi je pense que tu ferais si je
pense que
la personne que tu es il y en a pas
d'autre puis le monde de suivre pour se
péter plus ça c'est dangereux de
justesse cette espèce de réflexion là
surtout au début de l'hiver passé c'est
dur décanter dans un créneau comme
précis comme le mien m'attend ne pas
devenir une caricature on crie on fait
offrir des affaires j'ai pas juste un
défi de comme gardé son style mais dès
qu'ils des volumes affichés ce que c'est
mettons les vidéos manon massé est ce
que c'est une démarche pour essayer des
fades contenu plus sérieux ou plus et
pau est ce que c'est parce calculer mais
mon but c'est de faire des trucs qui me
tente pas axé sur quel s gaye i fakty
marange et les bonbons surgelés fait
souvent ouais avec le crier non mais
j'ai encore du panaf à ses vidéos là à
croire que c'est picasso les bonbons
japonnais goût bizarre normes et il y en
a encore des youtube bruit qu'ils font
qu'ils font qui font plus correct
puisque son truc même je sais combien de
fois je peux goûter aux bonbons puis
rester crédible et puis il y en aura
d'autres vidéos de bonbons puis
dégustation et blanches mais j'adore ça
me fait rire le faire mais j'ai envie de
faire des jeux un peu plus sur d'autres
facettes de ma personnalité je pense
qu'on est complexe n'est pas juste et
unis est aussi la télé réalité ça fait
ça on présente les candidats comme des
personnages qu'on les connaît sous un
angle comme le modèle à la coiffeuse et
et a fait des pique des colères et ils
ont toutes un personnes qui comme c'est
trop facile
créer créer quelque chose avec deux
traits de caractère les taupes au choix
un peu parce que la télé va vite
20e minute pour tracer les lignes c'est
tout ce que je trouve ça cool une fois
qu'ils ont on est sorti puis qu'on peut
prendre que le contrôle de notre propre
contenu de créer notre propre à fond je
sais ce que tu fais tu sais ce que tu
fais depuis que de commencer s'est
décrite à propre affaire il ya personne
qui l'avantagent de justement pas être
dans un
structure déjà établis ou est ce qu'il
ya une chaîne de production puis que du
fait du moment que tu le fait justement
que le monde consommera passé entre les
mains de cette personne c'est plus que
tout
ouais audevant a très peu qui est un
avantage de toi tout faire c'est une des
avantages et désavantages et plein de
avantage mais au moins
l'authenticité de la personne derrière
le projet demeure intègre puis ça je
pense que ça fait que des influenceurs
puis des créateurs de contenu qui ont
quelque chose à dire
moi j'ai pas pour ce genre le bel moi je
me posais la question par rapport aux 50
qui deviennent des influenceurs et je me
disais mettons le yoyo la dernière
mouture daudet avant que ce soit à vide
lyon fait aux dés l'année d'après il ya
des nouveaux candidats
c'est fini je me suis questionnée sur
est ce que le fait d'avoir déjà fort de
wing halling est-ce que ça prolonge la
dépôt la durée de vie mais là c'est
pareil mais le l'intérêt du monde c'est
sûr que oui par contre je pense que il
ya beaucoup de monde qui ont fait au
débat même avec moi qui ont sorti avec
déchets vraiment énorme
mais premièrement pluies vont avoir du
monde entre le sun quinze mille six cent
mille - ça va valoir quelque chose a
étendu à quinze mille deux cent mille
abonnés si ça c'est la première mesure
c'est déjà parce que il est arrivé
plusieurs fois qu'on m'a approché pour
des campagnes et on maudit hommes on va
prendre quelqu'un daudet ça coûte moins
cher c'est sur ces vous êtes ma
compétition gars c'est que je fais ici
je m'en veux beaucoup de gens parce que
la cause des téléréalités il ya beaucoup
de monde qui a quand les choses sont
beaucoup manqué dans les sorties qui
sont mis à accepter justement des
contrôles pour moins cher que ça fait
descendre la valeur de tout le monde
sauf que je pense que met-on je prends
mon exemple avec l'exemple de jesse
aussi on a tellement frappé sur le
créneau du véganisme et on que là les
gens qui nous suivent
c'est des gens qui s'intéressent à ce
et puis ça je sais que ça va rester
dense que du monde qui ont fait voler
ton le tout mangé un steak en soirée
c'est surtout le titre en cash et non de
nom depuis 20 kg portant des noms plus
ou moins ça mec se nomme il est ok par
exemple mais je serai capable vegan non
parce que je pense que ce soit mais je
comprends tout que l'aspect les animaux
nous appartiennent pas et se met pas
souvent chaud s'est mis dans le même
panier de le sort qu'on réserve aux
animaux puis pour moi ces deux débats
c'est comme je sais qu'il ya des façons
quand même respectueuse de pouvoir
manger des oeufs c'est juste que c'est
pour réglementer suffisamment pour pour
moi je trouve que la première étape
avant qu'on vire tous deux gagnent je
veux pas des mots ni retombe sa mission
mais merde a tenté de remettre des vrais
nord c'est pourquoi les vaches peuvent
être après trois petites cordes tout
l'hiver c'est ça le problème de la faire
avec ça mettons que tu parles de type
ski bio les télés le boeuf bio puis les
yeux fringe complètement cessé que si
admettons pour la pour la quantité de
boeuf qui consommaient s'il fallait que
les boeufs à s en remettre par 100 m des
espaces on n'a pas sa place au québec
pour toute la viande consommée mais que
c'est le problème est là si on voulait
que les poules soit libre qui compte
comme ils veulent ça aide vraiment des
centaines de milliers dans des petites
cages de rien tata douzaine de écouterez
soit quinze pièces telles que des
erreurs mais c'est ça le prix d'essai
seul problème exact c'est bien sûr
effectivement sur ce que le terrain des
affaires je me paie pas parce qu'ils
sont jaloux de 1 kw 115 places
le padd après sait qui est le monde en
achète plus pêcher ce poisson qu'il ya
comme sous le pression sur la touche
quand je me dis bien la question c'est
vraiment juste les normes et qui sont là
devraient pas permis d une affaire entre
c'est une toute autre traqué par les que
tu es abonnés de suivre parce que tu es
vega ben oui tout le monde a trouvé
comment à la nissan leaf sceller les
émanations comme paris le titre going on
se croise on est ensemble la guinée car
oui fullmark il y avait ces belles caves
est organisée pour l'ouverture mais nous
y avons aussi genre un gars qui créent
des tchats bottes pour détecter de la
maladie mentale dans une compagnie
start-up genre à montréal il ya un gars
qui fait de l'intelligence artificielle
de google comme le mappage en fait avec
alanis vers la fin mais elle est super
cool si puissamment je pense qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui vont rester
puis d'autres qui vont essayer de
marquer mon jeu comme avec star académie
dans le fantôme ou deux par année
même chose pour la voix et les 48 the
town et puis on s'en souviennent de trop
et encore la voix de nos enfants
j'adore mon les compétitions musicales
mais la voix de j'ai de la difficulté à
m'attacher y en a tellement de candidats
amélie qui sait de quel jamais pardon la
fête la voix ce temps souligné sue
sekita blanc liana bureau qui l'a chanté
d'audience et j'adore ce matin était
comme une actrice de théâtre est le sien
on peut être mais alors pas du tout
l'air rock le real a quand même sage le
web en 2015
3ème année je travaillais sur la voie
c'est vrai c'est quoi son nom
liana bureau non adaptés à la pointe
c'était la même année qui est qualifié
matthew goss qui mais je travaille à mon
prêt flux constant hors la loi et aux
faits exécutrice des gains et l'on voit
le poids à sa fille zohra charentes
était trop jeune les plus violents jean
pierre ferland bon plc est vitamines
m'entendre parler parce que je sais que
tu as fait ça arrive sud puis nous a
demandé comment un peu plus tôt soit
pour ça c'est parce que là je m'envoie
un événement le lancement de l'album ce
soir il faut que sophie durocher parle
de toi mais c'est où ça vaut 100 m aucun
restaurant proche
je me rappelle pas disons faut se
regarder courriel les invitations se
souleva allaitent à ses coûts vega doit
faire un bon système
fulham n'a pas ce que j'ai mangé une
barre mars la pile est un abonné qui me
dit que je condamne et les orangs outans
cause de lui le meilleur
ce sujet mme thunborg le pasteur louis
je l'aï reçue en cadeau je n'ai même pas
acheter mike mcfaul a gaspillé al existe
le les orangs outans il ya des sujets
sensibles et j'enregistrais janvier le
père laurent goutard dodin mars des fois
j'ai vu ma question ça va plus loin se
fixe comme les pailles c'est dangereux
lycée des réflexes et collègues qui sont
pas cohérents il ya des réflexes
écologiques sont cohérents avec
l'ensemble des choses mais mettons-les
paris l'été et beaucoup de monde dix ans
l est pas et l'on coupe est passé dessus
des poissons c'est oui ça tu déposes ans
qui sont encore plus des poissons c'est
manger des poissons
[Rires]
je comprends le démo départ oui mais
pour moi c'est la bonne conscience des
gens qui veulent pas faire livrer
j'espère c'est ce moi je t'ai fait que
soit leur chauffage chez nous sauf que
tu conduis un 4 4 diesel d'encours
l'outil et je dois faire une critique
d'appsfire d'occupation double ils ont
fait un quiz écologique sur l'île de
plastique
ouais pendant que deux candidats ont
parcouru pas loin de quarante mille
kilomètres d'avion pour deux ans mais je
suis comme cela sans veut partir sur les
débats écologique car c'est sûrement
c'est une question tellement vaste qu'il
permettrait vraiment vous l'êtes
écologique on viderait plus beaucoup
beaucoup de choses comment mais je
lisais dernièrement par rapport à au
carbone et l'empreinte de carbone dans
planète des avions qui décollent ballet
aérien les compagnies aériennes ils sont
régis par un quota d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui est balancé par un
coteau des industries je comprends je
comprenais pas exactement qu'est ce
qu'ils étaient or il est ainsi alice
disait que c'était c'était pas si nocif
on peut penser que si loin mais c'est
parce que cécile expliqué non mais non
mais ces compagnies aériennes devaient
compenser par leurs quotas dans d'autres
en redistribuant ailleurs les gens sont
écologiques jusqu'à temps que ça leur
enlève quelques formations initiales ils
veulent aller dans le sud dans l'avion
c'est que ça pollue pas mais là je veux
beaucoup d'espacé en moins a menti au
fbi - qui demande dans l'avion plus que
tout pollué que son siège c'est ce
serait beaucoup de trucs comme ça qu'on
vaut pas plus loin mon giro mais pas de
pain et l'eau avec mon nom soca cola
mais sa taille aussi il ya aussi
l'aspect tu dis quand qu'y voir des
options
je vais les prendre et nettoyer des
options comme pomas on peut boire de
même 5 avant de passer une option qui
les dentistes sortir sur l'érosion
dentaire le ils vont dire la paille très
bon je vois des options réel c'est pour
que le monde peut changer leurs
habitudes de vie sans trop décalé de ce
qui ferait normalement je pense que ça
va être
moi je garde toujours un sac en
plastique pour aller faire mon épicerie
je laisse dans mon roman comme en terme
de la semaine passée on avait
jean philippe sire chef de gan qui terme
et on parlait des manteaux le parti
scott a pas d'autre option qu'a fourrure
pour rester au chaud doit mettre la
fourrure mais c'est un manteau ou si
chaud non mais mettons luv le 200 m on
serait vraiment on serait vraiment comme
on se regarde est vraiment pas son juge
avez vous vu aller même si aujourd'hui
ça existe encore de quoi chaude de
douches chaudes ou pour le même prix qu
ici pas d'animaux parce que les gens ont
beaucoup des blocages mettons sur le
cueillir
mais sont peu élevés jeux pour les
enfants
je préfèrerais qu'on fasse quelque chose
avec compte mettre aux vidanges c'est de
toute façon on vieillit l'eau ce qui me
suis pas toujours le cas ce soir mais ça
ça devrait pas mais c'est que des fois
c'est comme c'est pas de boycotter un
truc c'était que
des normes mais admettons pour la
fourrure les tissus des animaux qui sont
élevés juste pour ce n'était quand même
la nourriture pour animaux
ils font beaucoup de mal et 100% poulet
label qualité je commets news monde qui
ont pas d'argent juste pas que mes
chômage la sq il ne faut pas croire mais
je mangerai mieux que 10 du monde vivant
et ça comme on écrit on est très
incohérent mais boîtes en même temps ce
que tu dit le ciss ces supports
mais sauf qu'elle tenait encore mettre
l'humain dans une hiérarchie plus
importante que d'autres doté des choses
moi je vais je comprends ce que
j'étudierais pour que c'est le spécisme
j'espère que mes shows mange des
restante de poulet qui ont été broyés
puis qu'ils peuvent rien faire d'autre
je voudrais pas qu'ils aient comme
manger des beaux intelligents de la
belgique ce qui aurait pu nourrir des
humains japon peut être comme ça chez
fonderie dans ma tête ça ce propos moi
et mon chômage mieux qu'un humain en
afrique ouailles à chaud les aime le
fait mes bébés
je comprends qu'on le plus d'empathie ou
en plus deux pour les jeunes qui nous
ressemblent blues le thé les eaux du
menton c'est sûr que si tu favorise la
survie d'un être humain à la survie d'un
animal sp6 purs et durs vont me dire qu'
il n'y a pas de différence mais si si il
y en a une différence
et puis je suis d'accord que s'ils la
boivent deux tons chauds avoir ton show
puis avait pas un être humain est dans
le besoin effectivement c'est quand même
un petit peu ce qui arrive parce que
quand pour faire de la belle nourriture
bio pour la nourriture des chats josy
llop à un milliard de de l'inventaire là
c'est sûr qu'à manille silva en bourse
de juillet par ailleurs chez eux au lieu
d'aider shop in the valley peuvent être
de garde
or sachez monsieur et on était curieux
de ce très bien sont carnivores à la
base ça marche très bien y retrouve tout
ce qu'ils trouvent dans les plans
beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts que leurs
animaux sur ça pour ça puis ça
marcherait bien faut que tu saches la
main et j'ai même pas moi si j'avais des
enfants
pigé tvgs que je leur imposerai si je
serai combat recueilleront large et
décideront les entrants sur leur pose la
question à leur expliquant très bien
leur viande vient d'où
mais aussi des égouts qui n'ont pas
d'enfant je détestais ce c'est pourquoi
ce pas ce cadeau pareil et faisaient
trop qui est devenu mais c'est vraiment
le on voulait me rendre végétarien façon
est vraiment efficace il faudrait que je
suis moi même les animaux c'est exact
c'est ça la question
je deviendrai végétariens se serait
incarné beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui ce
week end bikenge est aussi bien bien
wright alors pour les quatre personnes
qui n'ont pas fermé
lana être merci mon livre est en vente
l'acheter si vous voulez tout le monde
était plus d'argent moi quand vous
parlez vous l'achetez juste sabotant la
bibliothèque ce que vous voulez côté
mais oui des bibliothèques
en plus je fais des conférences dans les
bibliothèques et les bibliothécaires
m'ont dit qu'ils sont réservées les
agents cinq noms avant chez soit
disponible fait que le chemin contre
tous les auteurs qui haïssent les des
billets tech 1 qui disent à leurs en les
privant du millénaire comme
techniquement
il ya un fonds pour les gens qui ont des
livres en braille tech mais je pense que
quand on vient comme un genre le support
des failles koulikoro ex ge wind et adam
g 16 euros de l'heure avec mon livre
quelques mois on va compter qu'elle va
la voir matt est là bas mais surtout
suivi nous abonnez vous à l'écouté pour
savoir ce que vous avez dit dans l'intro
tabarnak les bas de caisse et pl c'est
super le fun mais pourquoi qui ont
affirmé les camions sur son pénis quant
à lui
[Musique]